GOOD MORNING LET'S GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WITH BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON
EDUCATION SO IF THIS ISN'T THE
ONE FOR YOU TIME TO GET OFF THE
BUS.
THE ITEMS TODAY WILL BE EL ALL
HOLD OPEN ITEMS WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THEM IN ORDER.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM SIX SIX
ZERO ZERO HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW ISSUE NUMBER ONE UP
[inaudible]
WANDA.
GEN ONE IF YOU WOULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD
STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT.
TO VOTE GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
AGAIN.
DECENT CONSTANT TORRICELLA ALE
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AGAIN.
DAVID HEYMAN BEING OUT.
OF THE LAW. TO GET AHEAD OF YOU.
AND DAVID SEWER CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER.
THE LAW AND YOU KNOW I HAVE
THANK YOU YOU ARE.
LINED UP EXACTLY IN ORDER IS
YOU'RE LISTED ON THE AGENDA.
ALL THE INSTRUCTION TO WANTS TO
START.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS ALL.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
DISCUSS UC HASTINGS.
A LOS BUDGET HERE THIS MORNING --
UC HASTINGS IS AFFILIATED WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM BUT IS GOVERNED BY ITS
OWN BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
ARE LOCATED IN SAN FRANCISCO IT
PRIMARILY SERVES STUDENTS
SEEKING INTEREST DOCTOR DEGREE
BUT ALSO AS A MASTER OF LOS
PROGRAMMING A MASTERS OF STUDIES
IN ALL PROGRAM.
I AM TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
UC HASTINGS AND ALL NINE AND
THIRTY FOUR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS.
OF THESE EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTEEN
WERE JD STUDENTS ELSE WISHING
FOR A STRESS DOCTOR PROGRAM THIS
YEAR WAS. 440-003-0020 SIX
DOLLARS AND TOOL WHEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EAST HASTINGS SO BUDGET
PRIMARILY FUNDED BY GENERAL FUND
AND TUITION AND FEES.
IS EIGHTY NINE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND BEING. NINETEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RIGHT TO TWO
POINT 5% AUGMENTATION HE SEES
THINGS THIS REPRESENTS AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONGOING.
I THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES ONE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT UC
HASTINGS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS.
IN TOTAL GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS THE COLLEGE WILL
BE SIXTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES BEFORE YOU
IN THIS ITEM THE FIRST IS -- THE
ONGOING BASED INCREASE AND THE
SECOND IS THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
NOW WITH REGARD TO THE BASE
INCREASE.
WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION ON ADOPTING
REJECTING OR MODIFYING THE
PROPOSAL -- BUT WE DO OFFER SOME
ANALYSIS ON THE LAW SCHOOLS THE
OVERALL BUDGET CONDITION -- THE
LAW SCHOOL HAS HAD -- A DEFICIT.
IN RECENT YEARS.
AND IT'S IN THE PROCESS OF
ELIMINATING THE DEFICIT.
AND YOUR GENDER I TURN YOUR
ATTENTION TO PAGE FIVE WHICH THE
DISPLAYS A TABLE OF THE SCHOOLS --
OPERATING BALANCES AND RESERVES --
STARTING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND PROJECTIONS IN
LATER YEARS.
NO ONE THING I WOULD NOTE WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS TABLE IS
THAT A FIFTY AS YOU'LL SEE IN
FIGURE.
TO THE TABLE INCLUDE SOME
FUNDING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED HASTINGS -- FOR A
FINANCIAL AID INITIATIVE.
I WOULD PROVIDE FOR A HALF
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THEN THE SCHOOLS BEGINNING TO
SPEND THOSE FUNDS ARE BEGINNING
IN [inaudible]
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THIS FUNDING
DOESN'T HAVE AN IMPACT ON HIS
TEAM'S OVERALL OPERATIONS ITS
ITS PROGRAMMATIC IN NATURE --
BUT THE FUNDS -- SKEW THE
NUMBERS SOMEWHAT SO IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE REVIEW WE REMOVE
THOSE -- FUNDS AND WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT IN NINETEEN TWENTY
HASTINGS PROJECTS WILL ACTUALLY
START REDUCING ITS DEFICIT
RATHER THAN INCREASING AS THE
TABLE MIGHT SUGGEST.
AT FIRST GLANCE.%
THE SCHOOL IS REDUCING ITS
DEFICIT PRIMARILY BY REDUCING --
TUITION DISCOUNTING -- IT HAD
INCREASED TUITION DISCOUNTING A
FEW YEARS AGO AND THAT'S WHAT
ORIGINALLY I WAS A KEY FACTOR
THAT LED TO THE BUDGET DEFICIT.
AND THE SCHOOL HAS A LONG TERM
PLAN. TO ADDRESS ITS DEFICIT AND
SO THE QUESTION BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IS IS THE COMMITTEE
COMFORTABLE THAT PLAN WHAT STEPS
IS THE SCHOOL IT EXPECTED TAKE
IN THE FUTURE.
AND IS IT IS A FAST ENOUGH WOULD
LIKE TO SEE FURTHER PROGRESS OR
IS IT DOES THAT SEEM ABOUT RIGHT.
NOW IN ADDITION TO THAT DURING
THE DEFICIT NUMBERS THAT THOSE
NUMBERS ALSO SKEW THE RESERVE
NUMBERS A BIT.
I'M WHEN WE REVIEWED WHEN WE
WROTE.
YOU KNOW A FACTORED OUT THAT
THAT INITIATIVE FUNDING OTHER
RESERVES WENT DOWN AND
EFFECTIVELY WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THE SCHOOL ANTICIPATED. TO
SPEND ALL OF ITS OPERATING
RESERVE AND WOULD START COVERING
OF THE REMAINING DEFICIT IN
OPERATIONS FROM ITS MAINTENANCE
RESERVE.
NOW THE SCHOOL IN OUR OFFICE
HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW TO INTERPRET
THIS.
THE SCHOOL MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SCHOOLS PERSPECTIVE IS THAT --
IT FEELS THAT BECAUSE THE
MAINTENANCE RESERVE IS FUNGIBLE
WITH THE OPERATING RESERVE --
IT'S A BIT ARBITRARY -- TO
DESIGNATE ONE FUNDING OR THE
OTHER AND AND THE TOTAL RESERVES
COMBINED AREON RESTRICTED AND
SO THE SCHOOL HAS COMPLETE.
ABILITY TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO
COVER ITS DEFICIT.
WHERE WE HAVE A BIT MORE CONCERN
WITH THIS APPROACH -- WHAT WHAT
WE FOUND IN THE PAST IS THE ONE
OF THE WAYS IN WHICH MAINTENANCE
BACKLOGS GROW?
AT STATE AGENCIES IS WHEN THEY
START USING FUNDS THAT WERE
DESIGNATED FOR MAINTENANCE
TOWARDS OTHER BUDGETARY
PRIORITIES.
AND SO THE FACT THAT THE SCHOOL
WILL HAVE TO START A SPENDING
DOWN ITS MAINTENANCE RESERVE.
A WE THINK.
RAISES FURTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S IT'S IT'S
TAKE DOING ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
THIS DEFICIT.
NO REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL OTHER
COMMITTEE MIGHT ALSO WONDER WELL
WHAT IS THE CONDITION OF A
HAZING FACILITIES TO DATE ARE
THEY IN GOOD SHAPE ARE THEY IN
BAD SHAPE.
AND OUR VIEW SUGGESTS THAT THE
SCHOOLS ACTUALLY AND AND
RELATIVELY BETTER SHAPE THAN
OTHER STATE AGENCIES YOU MIGHT
HAVE EXPERIENCED IN IN YOUR
HEARINGS.
AND THAT'S LARGELY BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS ADDRESS THIS BACKLOG
AYE THROUGH NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ACTIONS SO THE SCHOOL HAS TO
FACILITIES.
OF THOSE WHO WANT ONE IS WHAT IS
SLATED TO BE REPLACED FROM AN
WITH A NEW BUILDING THAT WILL
COME ONLINE SOON THAT WAS FUNDED
BY THE STATE A FEW YEARS AGO.
THE SECOND BUILDING HAS RECEIVED
SOME FUNDING FOR PROJECTS AND
IT'S LARGELY ADDRESS A LOT OF
ITS BACKLOG.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE -- SIX AND
YOU'LL SEE A TABLE THERE THAT
SHOWS HE THINGS.
ESTIMATE OF BACKLOG TODAY.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THE SCHOOL
HAS STARTED TO INCLUDE IN ITS
MAINTENANCE WAS PROJECTS THAT.
THE STATE SOMETIMES CONSIDERS TO
BE LOWER PRIORITY SO THINGS LIKE
CARPET REPLACEMENT'S ENTER YOUR
PAINTING.
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE ARE.
SCHEDULED TO HAPPEN BUT THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY CRITICAL --
BUILDING OPERATIONS PROJECTS
THAT YOU MIGHT SEE ANOTHER
AGENCIES THAT ARE IN MUCH FIFTH
HAVE FACILITIES WITH MUCH WORSE
CONDITION.
SO THAT THE ISSUE FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN THE CASE OF
HASTINGS IS -- TO SOME EXTENT
PAYING DOWN THE BACKLOG BUT
ULTIMATELY THE THE QUESTION
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IS HOW WILL
THE SCHOOL -- ADDRESS
MAINTENANCE IN THE FUTURE SO
THAT FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW IT
WILL BE ABLE TO START.
OF FUNDING MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
WITH ITS NEW BUILDING.
I'M SO GIVEN THE OUR ANALYSIS OF
THE CURRENT BACKLOG IN THE FACT
THAT THE SCHOOL HAS MAINTENANCE
RESERVES WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE PROPOSED
A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
MAINTENANCE AND DIRECT THE
SCHOOL INSTEAD TO FUND THESE
REMAINING.
OF PROJECTS FROM ITS MAINTENANCE
RESERVE.
AND THEN MOVING FORWARD WE ALSO
RECOMMEND AS WE DO IN THE CASE
OF UC AND CSU. TO DEVELOP A LONG
TERM PLAN TO ADDRESS ITS
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG -- OBVIOUSLY
THAT AGAIN THE CONSIDERATION
HEARD BE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT --
THERE THERE'S SOME BACKLOG WE
NEED TO BE PAID DOWN BUT
ULTIMATELY THAT PLAN WOULD WOULD --
DEVELOP OF A WAY FOR THE SCHOOL
TO SET ASIDE FUNDING EACH YEAR
SO THAT WHEN MEANS PROJECTS
PROJECTS ARE SCHEDULED HAS
FUNDING TO TO UNDERTAKE THOSE
PROJECTS.
THANK YOU ONE HAS TO QUESTION
LET ME ASK A QUESTION.
YOU PROBABLY COVER THIS AND IN
YOUR BEGINNING AND SLID RIGHT BY
MY OLD BRAIN BUT OUR ANALYSIS
REFLECTS THE TASTINGS WILL BEGIN
TO TAP ITS.
MAINTENANCE RESERVE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND HAVE
THREE POINT NINE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN THE CHART THAT I
JUST RECEIVED SO WAS THERE AND A
NEW ANALYSIS OR THE ANNOUNCED
THAT THE PRIMARY DIFFERENCE IS
THAT I FOR OUR ANALYSIS WE
EXCLUDED THAT DIVERSITY PIPELINE
INITIATIVE.
THAT'S WHAT SKEWS THE NUMBERS
FOR ACTUALLY SO THE TOTAL
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG HASTINGS IS
ONE WHAT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION.
THAT THE CHURCH -- WHICH YEAR.
WELL I'M LOOKING AT HASTINGS
REPORTED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
KANE HOLE -- YES I'M SORRY
THAT'S RIGHT.
I DON'T HEAR ANYBODY TALK ABOUT
SEISMIC WHAT'S THIS.
ZERO IS THERE A ANALYSIS OF
SEISMIC ISSUES YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GETTING  NEW BUILDING SO
PRESUMABLY WE'VE TAKEN.
CARE OF SEISMIC WITH THAT I HOPE
WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER ONE WELL
YOU ASSN.
EXCELLENT QUESTION -- MY AGAIN
DAVID SEWER IN THE CFO OF
HASTINGS.
OF THE SCHOOL HAS ITS CAMPUS IS
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVE.
A BUILDINGS THAT ARE YOU.
STE STATE SUPPORTED SUPPORT THE
SCHOOLS EDUCATIONAL MISSION.
AND THEN WE HAVE BUILDINGS THAT.
ARE EXHILARATING REPRISES
STUDENT HOUSING PERFECT EARLY.
OF WITH THE STATE SUPPORT FOR
THE REPLACEMENT ACADEMIC BILLION
GOLDEN GATE AVENUE WE WILL HAVE
SIZABLE THE UPGRADE ALL OF OUR
STATE SUPPORTED BUILDINGS.
OF THE BUILDING.
THE TWO HUNDRED MCALLISTER ST
RECEIVED THE SEISMIC UPGRADE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH IS ALSO
LESS THAN WE REPLACE THE
CARPETING IN.
THAT BUILDING -- BUT OF GREATER
CONCERN AND WHICH REALLY THE
DRAG A DRIVER OF OUR LONG RANGE
CAMPUS PLAN IS THE CRITICALITY.
OF ADDRESSING SEISMIC ISSUES AT
OUR STUDENT HOUSING FACILITY
THEY MAY BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTED
IN -- NINETEEN TWENTY NINE WE
ARE EMBARKING ON A PLAN WHICH
ARE BEING FAKE WE CAN DESCRIBE
MORE ARTICULATELY.
THAT WILL CREATE NEW STUDENT
HOUSING TO ALLOW US TO VACATE
THE NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
STRUCTURE.
SHIFT THE HEAD COUNT INTO THE TO
BE DEVELOPED BUILDING WHICH WERE
IN DEVELOPMENT NOW OF AND THEN
ALLOW FOR THE ULTIMATE
REHABILITATION OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE I RISE.
SO THE THE SEISMIC OF NEEDS OF
HASTINGS AS WELL AS THE UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA WRIT LARGE.
ARE SIGNIFICANT BUT IT REALLY
HOW ONE ADDRESSES THAT IS A
FUNCTION OF IF IT'S IN A STATE
SUPPORTED BUILDING OR IN IT AND
BUT BUILDING CARE TRIES ANOTHER
AS LONG AS HILLARY -- ENTERPRISE
OR EXTRAMURAL AND HOW ARE YOU
ADDRESSING.
WELL WITH LIBERTY AND NOW IF
THERE WOULD BE THE ISSUANCE OF
TAX EXEMPT THAT.
THE HASTINGS HAS THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE -- BONDS.
THOSE BONDS WOULD BE SUPPORTED
THROUGH THE REVENUES AT THE
STUDENT HOUSING GENERATES.
AND AND AND SO THE REVENUE BONDS
YES THE SETTLERS YES SO THEN HOW
WHAT YOUR TIME LINE.
WELL.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THE SCOPE OF
THE PROJECT WAS?
WHAT IS THE LIST OF BROAD
QUESTION YEAH I'M HAVING?
FUN DOLLARS OVER THE VOTE FOR
THE RE HAVE -- IT WOULD PROBABLY
EVER HER EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN REVENUE WHICH IS THE NEW
BUILDING WILL BE A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION YES.
OKAY SO WHAT WHAT WE WILL BE
WHAT'S THE NEW ACADEMIC BUILDING
IS ON LINE THAT WAS FUNDED.
BY THE STATE -- THAT WILL BE
READY OF OCCUPANCY AROUND
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR -- WE THEN
PLAN TO HAND OVER THE OLD
ACADEMIC BUILDING WHICH IS A
FOUR STORY BUILDING -- TO OUR
CONTRACTOR WHICH IS QUITE
CONSTRUCTION -- AROUND APRIL
TWENTIETH -- TWENTY TWENTY THEY
HAVE A TWO YEAR CONSTRUCTION
SCHEDULE -- SO WE HOPE THAT WILL
BE OPEN FOR BUSINESS JUNE --
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT BUILDING
I WILL BE FOURTEEN STORIES TALL --
TO HAVE THAT SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THE SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
SUBSIDIZE STUDENT UNITS -- IN
THOSE UNITS WILL BE SHARED
BETWEEN UC HASTINGS AND YOU SEE
SAN FRANCISCO -- AND IT'LL BE
GREAT EXPANDING -- WHAT I'D CALL
GRADUATE ACADEMIC VILLAGE IN THE
HEART OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THEN
WILL VACATE THE TWENTY SEVEN
STORY -- HOUSING STRUCTURE THAT
WE HAVE WHICH IS SEISMIC WE
CHALLENGE -- AND THAT WILL BE
COMPLETELY RENOVATED -- WITH THE
EXPECTATION BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ENDING AND JUNE --
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO GO FROM HOUSING
AROUND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
GRADUATES USE ON CAMPUS HOUSING
OVER A THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS -- WHICH OF
COURSE IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO -- IS A GREAT.
BENEFIT.
NOT ONLY TO YOU CASF AND
HASTINGS -- BUT ALSO TO THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO GET YOU ALL OF
TRACK WITH MY QUESTION BUT IS
SORT OF TIED INTO WHAT THE LA --
WAS TALKING ABOUT SO I THOUGHT
I'D JUMP ON SEISMIC IN THE
BUILDING ISSUES.
SURE SO ARE I WILL OF JUST BEGIN
BY SAYING HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS
OF COURSE -- THAT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET --
THE OVERALL -- GENERAL INCREASE
WILL ALLOW US TO GO INTO AN
EIGHTH YEAR WITHOUT TUITION --
RAISE ANY TUITION OF RAISING FOR
THE STUDENTS -- AND OF COURSE
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALLOW
US TO MAINTAIN OUR BUILDINGS --
IN GOOD WORKING ORDER -- HOW DID
pTHE STATE -- THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS -- THEY
DIDN'T ALLOCATE FUNDS THAT ALLOW
US TO BUILD A BRAND NEW ACADEMIC
BUILDING WHICH IS BEING BUILT ON
CURRENTLY ON AN EMPTY LOT -- AND
THEN LAST YEAR -- THROUGH AFTER
THE INITIATIVE OF SOME OF THE
PORTANTINO -- WE WERE PROVIDED
WITH A PUT DIVERSITY PIPE BY
GRANT TO CREATE -- CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARSHIP FOR GRADUATES OF THE
H. B. C. USE THIS WILL BE THE
FIRST YEAR THAT THAT -- GRANT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED -- AND WE
HAVE EVERY EXPECTATION THAT IT
WILL BE AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS
HAS BEEN VERY WELL RECEIVED BY
THE H. B. C. USE -- NATIONALLY.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE THE
DISCOUNTING PRACTICES THAT SET
OUT IN THE IN THE OUTLINE IS IS
I GUESS SECOND YES.
PRELIMINARY STREAM OF CONSCIOUS
QUESTIONS I MEAN IS THIS COMMON
IN.
LAW SCHOOL BUSINESS THESE DAYS
AND I NOTICED IT'S NOT NEED
BASED ITS ITS MERIT BASED SO
IT'S ESSENTIALLY IN THE FORM OF
A SCHOLARSHIP BUT WE CALL IT A
DISCOUNT I GUESS.
SO YEAH -- FOR FOLLOWING TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT A REALLY AROUND --
TWENTY TEN THE APPLICATION POOL
DECREASED BY AS MUCH AS 40%
NATIONALLY.
AND SO THAT RAISE THE
COMPETITIVENESS -- FOR QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS TO LAW SCHOOL AND LAW
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
IN PARTICULAR IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS THE
NEW UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
BUT ALSO -- PEPPER NINE CHAT MEN
WILL LOS ANGELES SOUTHWESTERN --
THE VERY SCHOOLS BEGAN -- TO
THEY CALL THE SCHOLARSHIP MONEY
WAS ACTUALLY TUITION DISCOUNTING
WE WENT -- IN ORDER TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE IN THE MARKETPLACE
FROM AROUND THE 25230% DISCOUNT
I WHICH WAS THE ORDINARY I THINK
MOST SCHOOLS FALL THAT -- TO
AROUND 42405% DISCOUNTING OVER
THE YEARS FROM AROUND -- TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OTHER SCHOOLS
INCLUDING -- OUR SISTER SCHOOLS
LIKE DAVIS AND IRVINE I HAD
DISCOUNT RATES ABOUT 505560%
AWAY -- ESSENTIALIST SO -- IS IN
THE 65270% TUITION DISCOUNTING A
RANGE -- AND THEY ARE LARGELY
BEING SUPPORTED BY THEIR
CAMPUSES SO ONE OF OUR
DISADVANTAGES AS A STANDALONE --
HAS BEEN THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
CENTRAL CAMPUS TO HELP SUBSIDIZE --
THAT -- TUITION DISCOUNTING OF
COURSESTUDENTS BENEFIT -- FROM
SOME TUITION DISCOUNTING BECAUSE
TUITION IS QUITE EXPENSIVE THESE
DAYS BUT IT'S NOT REALLY A
SUSTAINABLE MODEL AND WE HAVE
SEEN APPLICATIONS STARTING TO
RISE -- NOT TO THE LEVELS PRIOR --
TO TWENTY TWELVE BUT I THINK
THAT THAT STARTING TO EVEN OUT
AND I THINK SCHOOLS GENERALLY
FOLLOWING.
THE TREND THAT WE ARE WHICH IS
TO RATCHET BACK -- A PART IT IS
OF COURSE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A BALANCED BUDGET SO WE'RE
NOW IN WITH THIS YEAR WE RATCHET
BACK TO OUR HISTORICAL NORM --
BUT WE HAVE A TAIL BECAUSE THE
SECOND YEAR STUDENTS THE THIRD
YEAR STUDENTS GOT THE DISCOUNT
OF THAT 42405% SO UNTIL THEY'VE
GRADUATED -- IT'S A COUPLE OF
YEARS TO GET BACK TO OUR
HISTORICAL MEMBERS.
WELL I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THEN
WHEN MY FRIENDS IN ACADEMIA PUSH
BACK ON SO MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WANT TO START ANOTHER LAW SCHOOL.
IS NOT A GOOD MARKET -- TO SO
THE THING YES IT'S POLITICALLY --
THIN ICE FROM YOU TO TAKE A
STAND ON THAT.
I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT --
RIGHT NOW THE LAW SCHOOLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SEEM TO BE A
SEVEN THE MARKET WELL IF --
THERE WAS AN ISSUE FOR ME -- IT
WOULD BE MAKING SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND PUBLIC INTEREST.
HAVE THE SUPPORT TO LAW SCHOOL
AND THROUGH -- SOME SORT OF
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS WE DO HAVE
AND ARE ACTIVE IN PI CAP AND OF
COURSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY -- FORGET IS -- ANY
LOANS ARE NOT PAID BACK AFTER
TEN YEARS AND MAY BE UP FOR THE
TIME BEING EXACTLYTHEY SAY
THEY'RE GOING TO RIGHT HAVEN'T
SEEN VERY MANY RIGHT YEAH YEAH
EXACTLY SO JUST ONE FINAL
QUESTION FOR ME -- BECAUSE I'M
CURIOUS HOW DO YOU WHO GETS THE
DISCOUNTS HOW DO YOU DO YOU HAVE
A CUT LINE I MEAN IS IT BASED ON
YOUR LSAT SCORES AND YOUR GPA
IT'S A MIXTURE -- SO WE DO HAVE
NEEDS BASED -- AND ABOUT 85290%
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE NEEDS BASED --
BASED ON FASTER AND AND OTHER --
STANDARD -- METRICS -- SO EVEN
WHEN THEY GET MERIT BASED
SCHOLARSHIPS THE VERY OFTEN --
NEEDY STUDENTS IN ANY CASE --
BUT WE DO OF USE IT
STRATEGICALLY -- TO TRY TO
ATTRACT STUDENTS WITH HIGHER
LCTS AND HIGHER GPA IS PART OF
THE ARMS RACE QUITE FRANKLY IS
HOW WE ARE RANKED BY.
U. S. NEWS THIS AND SO STUDENTS
ARE MAKING JUDGMENTS SUPPORTERS
ARE MAKING JUDGMENTS -- BASED ON
THE PROCEEDS ARE STATUS OF THE
SCHOOL AND BECAUSE US NEWS TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT -- CITY IN GPA --
IT HAS A DIRECT EFFECT ON THE
SORT OF SPIRALING IN THE FUTURE --
WHAT LEVEL STUDENT YOU CAN
ATTRACT TO YOUR SCHOOL? THREE DO
YOU IN -- IF YOU DECLARE WILL
SAY JUST TO ADD TO THAT
THE GERMAN ROUTE THEN.
WE ALSO USE IT TO ATTRACT
PROGRAM CALLED OTHER LEGAL AND
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM WE
ARE -- AND WE OP IS DIRECTED WE
BASICALLY MAINTAIN 20% OF OUR
SLT SO WHERE ACTUAL OVER 20%
OFF FOR THE INCOMING CLASS -- TO
ADMIT STUDENTS -- FROM
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED AND HAVE OVERCOME
DISADVANTAGE AND NOW -- PRESENT
GOOD AS GOOD PROSPECT FOR LAW
SCHOOL THEY TYPICALLY ON AVERAGE
HAVE LOWERED -- CITIES IN GPAS
BUT AS A PUBLIC INSTITUTION WE
OUT THIS YEAR TO TURN FIFTY
YEARS OLD ARE COMMON HARRIS WAS
A WE HAVE GRADUATE -- AND WE'RE
VERY JEFF ADACHI -- IT DOUBLE --
FEDERAL JUDGE ROLE WE HAVE
GRADUATES AND TO A VERY PROUD OF
THE PROGRAM AND IT REALLY DOES
GIVE A TRUE OPPORTUNITY TO
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FACED
DISADVANTAGE -- PRIOR TO GETTING
TO ALL SCHOOL DO YOU DO YOU
MAINTAIN STATISTICS ON THE
DISCOUNTING PROGRAM AND IT NEVER
IS.
CATEGORIES OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF INDIVIDUALS WE DIRECTED BY
THE EEKEND SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU HAPPEN TO
PROVIDE THIS DATA ABSOLUTELY.
THE REALLY QUESTIONS NO.
JUST LOOK AT BUT NOT RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS A PROMINENT LAWYER
SONS SO.
IN HIGH PLACES NOW.
WELL I HAVE NO QUESTIONS SO I
APPRECIATE WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OFTEN APPRECIATE THAT
I CUT YOU OFFICER PHOTO NARAL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INFORMATION
ON THE SEISMIC ISSUE I THINK
THAT'S A NOT JUST YOU SEE BUT TO
SEE ISSUE AND I HEAR VERY LITTLE
ABOUT.
SEISMIC IN SO -- EYES.
I'M GONNA START ASKING ABOUT
WELL WHEN WE ARE COMPLETED WITH
OUR LONG RANGE CAMPUS PLAN THE
ACADEMIC VILLAGE 1100% OF THE
CAMPUS WILL HAVE BEEN
SEISMICALLY UPGRADED.
YOUR STATE AND NON STATE.
AND WILL BE IN MODERN COAL
COMPLAINTS THAT WILL BE WILL
MAINTAIN GOING.
FOR YOU.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ITEMS SIXTY ONE TWENTY
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY THERE
ARE THREE ISSUES WE'LL START
WITH ISSUE TO ZIP BOOKS.
SO.
HOW ARE YOU SIR THANK YOU?
I'M GREAT.
HAVE YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD STARTING MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT SIR.
CHRISTOPHER EXAM WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MONEY.
JUSTIN CONCENTRATION DALY AGAIN.
LOCUSTS FROM THE STATE LIBRARY.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING FOR BEING
HERE.
WHO WANTS TO START?
SURE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY
SERVES A CRITICAL ROLE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT BY SERVING AS THE
CENTRAL REFERENCE AND RESEARCH
LIBRARY FOR THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE LIBRARY
PROVIDES CRITICAL ASSISTANCE AND
DISTRIBUTES FEDERAL FUNDING TO
THE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS.
AND NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
LIBRARIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A ONE TIME --
INVESTMENT IN THESE BOOKS
PROGRAM OF ONE MILLION DOLLARS --
GENERAL FUND.
THE PROGRAM ENABLES A WITHOUT
FURTHER ACCESS TO BOOKS AND
LIBRARY MATERIALS -- THROUGHOUT --
DIGITAL -- INFRASTRUCTURE SO IT
CERTAINLY ENABLE SAP PATRONS --
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO
BOOKS THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO OBTAIN AT THEIR LOCAL
LIBRARY [inaudible]
HELLO. TO GIVE A LITTLE MORE
CONTEXT ON A WHAT THE FUNDS
WOULD BE SPENT ON OF THE WAY THE
PROGRAM WORKS IS A PATRON AT A
LIBRARY REQUESTS A BOOK.
THE LIBRARY THEN.
AS AN ESTABLISHED LINE OF CREDIT
THE RAMS ON AND PURCHASED THE
PURCHASES THE BOOK ON BEHALF OF
THE PATRON AND THE STATE.
ULTIMATELY PAYS FOR THE BOOK.
THE BOOK IS DELIVERED TO THE
PATRON THE PATRON USES THE BOOK
RETURNS IT TO THE LIBRARY AND AT
THAT POINT THE LIBRARY EITHER
DECIDES TO MAINTAIN THE BOOK
KEEP IT OR ARE TO SELL THROUGH
ITS FOUNDATION.
THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
OVERSEEN BY NORTH NET WHICH IS A
LIBRARY COOPERATIVE SYSTEM IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND ACCORDING THE STATE LIBRARY
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
THE ONE MILLION WOULD BE SPENT
ON BOOK PURCHASES ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND BUCKS ESTIMATES.
THE REMAINING HUNDRED THOUSAND
WOULD BE SPENT ON NORTH NOTES
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
WE REVIEW THIS PROPOSAL -- WE
FOUND THAT THAT ONE OF THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM IS
TO ENSURE THAT -- RURAL
LIBRARIES WITH RELATIVELY FEW
RESOURCES.
I CAN MEET PATRON REQUESTS FOR
LIBRARY RESOURCES.
AND THAT OVERARCHING GOAL IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEEN A LONG
ESTABLISHED GOLDEN STATE LAW.
WE'RE CONCERNED HOWEVER THAT THE
PROPOSAL LACKED A COUPLE OF KEY
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN IT WAS
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
A WALK THROUGH SOME OF THOSE --
ISSUES.
OF THE FIRST IS THAT THE THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF DIDN'T FULLY
ARTICULATE -- THE THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE PROBLEM SO THERE WAS NO
DATA FOR EXAMPLE ON A WHICH
LIBRARIESHAVE DIFFICULTY
MEETING PATRON REQUEST WHICH
LIBRARIES ARE RELATIVELY UNDER
RESOURCE.
AND THOSE DIFFICULT TO KNOW IF
HE CURRENT PROGRAM IS WAS
TARGETED ADEQUATELY.
A WE DID FIND THAT FROM SOME
HISTORICAL INFORMATION.
BUDGET DATA FOUND THAT -- THE
LIBRARIES ARE CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM THEY
SPENT ABOUT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF THEIR LOCAL RESOURCES TO
REQUIRE PRINT MATERIALS.
THAT'S FAR IN EXCESS OF WHAT THE
STATE -- IS ABOUT PROVIDING FOR
THE BOOKS PROGRAM ABOUT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS ALL OF
THE LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS SOME
OF THEM HAVE A OF MATERIALS
ACQUISITION BUDGET OF ZERO AND
SOME OF THEM HAVE.
LARGER ACQUISITION BUDGET SO --
IT JUST A QUESTION OF WHICH OF
THESE LIBRARIES ARE AT HIGHEST
NEED.
ANOTHER FACTOR THAT WASN'T
INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSAL WERE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES -- TO THE
BOOKS THAT COULD HELP ROLE
LIBRARIES ME PATRON DEMAND FOR
EXAMPLE A BETTER USING
ELECTRONIC RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE
A RATHER THAN PRINT MATERIALS.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THERE ARE%
SOME BASIC INFORMATION THAT WE
HAD REQUESTED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HISTORICAL
SPENDING IN FUNDING IN THE
PROGRAM IN WHICH LIBRARIES HAVE
RECEIVED A BOOK PURCHASES AND
HOW MANY BOOKS HAVE BEEN
PURCHASED SO FAR.
AND WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT REQUEST
WE HAVEN'T.
SEEN THE DATA YET AND SO WE
CAN'T COMMENT ON WHETHER THE
PROJECTED SIXTY THOUSAND BUCKS
IS IN LINE WITH WHAT THE PROGRAM
HAS SEEN THUS FAR AND IF THERE'S
ANY.
SO SOMEBODY COLLECTING DATA.
A MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT NORTH
NET WHICH OVERSEES THE PROGRAM
GATHERS DATA AND SUBMITS A TO
THE STATE LIBRARY -- WHERE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING AGAIN WITHIN
MINISTRATION ON ON THAT THEY
INDICATED THAT THEY COULD GET US
SOME INFORMATION BUT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IT YET SO IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF?
OF GETTING AT THIS POINT SO WE
CAN REVIEW IT.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM GETTING THE
BOOKS BACK INTO THE LIBRARY
SYSTEM.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
BOOKS GENERALLY ARE RETURNED TO
THE LIBRARY SYSTEM SOME
LIBRARIES HAVE A DIFFICULTY --
TRACKING THE BOOKS SO IF THEY
DON'T OF BAR CODED PROPERLY IS
SOMETIMES IT MIGHT GET LOST WITH
THEIR OTHER BOOKS AND SO THERE'S
SOME.
THERE'S SOME DATA ISSUES THERE
WITH WITH TRACKING WHETHER OR
NOT THE BOOKS ARE RETURNED MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MOST OF THE
BOOKS ARE RETURNED THERE ARE
SOME THAT THAT MAY NOT GET
RETURN BUT THAT DUTCH BASED ON A
REVIEW THAT WAS DONE OF THE
PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO.
CLICK AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM.
STATE LIBRARIAN -- I'M SORRY I'M
TO GIVE A RECOMMENDED WITH A
RECOMMENDATION THAT I WALK YOU
THROUGH AND I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT REALLY CUT YOU -- BUDGET
JUST A RECOMMENDATION THERE ON
WE WE HAD RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GET AN IMPROVED PLAN
FIRST FOR THOSE OF BOOKS
PROPOSAL THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WE HAD.
BECAUSE THE LARGEST BECAUSE IT
FOR TWO WEEKS AWAY FROM THE MAY
REVISION -- IT'S IT'S UNLIKELY
WE GET OUT OF AN UPDATED AND PER
PLAN IN THAT TIME TO BE IN
REASONABLE FOR THE CELEBRITY
DEVELOP THAT PLANTS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TWO OPTIONS. ONE
IS TO REQUEST ADMINISTRATION
COME BACK NEXT YEAR ANOTHER
ALTERNATIVE IS TO APPROPRIATE
THE FUNDS AND CONDITION THE
RELEASE ON THOSE FUNDS ON ON
GETTING -- SOME MORE INFORMATION
AND HAVING A SORT OF DEAL BE SEE
REVIEW PROCESS.
SUCH THE RECOMMENDATION WE HAD
THANK YOU.
WELL I WOULD ASSUME THAT.
IT WILL BE SOMEBODY WILL BE
COLLECTING SOME DATA AND
CRUNCHING SOME NUMBERS.
MAKING SURE THAT THE PRO PROGRAM
IS THE MOST EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
WAY BUT IT IT SEEMS SORT OF
INNOVATIVE TO ME WE'RE NOT
APPROVING ANYTHING TODAY TO HOLD
OPEN ITEM BUT THANK YOU.
SIR SAID SINCE YOU'RE HOLDING
THE ITEM OPENID WOULD THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND TALKED AFTER THE
MAY REVISION.
I WANNA HAVE A FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR I THINK IF YOU
KNOW A BOOK ANYTHING ELSE IT'S
NOT A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY IT'S
AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM IF IT
SERVES PEOPLE IN RURAL AREAS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING TO LIBRARIES AND
SECURING BOOKS AND WE SEEM TO
GET THE BOOKS.
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM IT'S ABOUT
80% RETURN RIGHT -- IF YOU YOU
KNOW CATTY CORNER FROM YOUR
DISTRICT OFFICE HE WALKED TO THE
MAIN LIBRARY RIVERSIDE USES THAT
MAKE HIM RIGHT AND WHAT GIVE YOU
CHAPTER AND VERSE ON THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE IN THE
POPULARITY THAT IT HAS.
BUT I'M SURE THERE'S A WAY TO
YOU KNOW QUANTIFY THE EFFECT
YEAH PROGRAM OVER TIME AND
THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT THE NEXT TIME
AROUND FOR SURE.
IF NOT BEFORE YEAH IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING FOR HOW HUGE -- AS
AMAZON IS -- THEY HAVE
DIFFICULTY DEALING WITH LARGE
GROUP CLIENTS AND THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE.
I MEAN IT'S A LONGER DISCUSSION
BUT IT'S AN ISSUE WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT'S GOING TO ALLOW THE
EASIER.
COLLECTION OF THE DATA WITH WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THE HANDS ON
PERFECT.
TELL YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
NOT LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
ONE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT THE LUNCH AT
THE LIBRARIES PROGRAM -- THESE --
INVESTMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
ENABLE LOCAL LIBRARIES TO DRAW
DOWN -- FEDERAL -- FUNDING TO
SUPPORT AT SUMMER LUNCH PROGRAMS
TO THE LIBRARY -- THIS WAS FIRST
FUNDED -- IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET WHAT THEY ONE
MILLION ONE TIME AUGMENTATION AS
WELL [inaudible]
HELLO.
OUR SYSTEM THE RECOMMENDATION IS
GOING TO SOUND SOMEWHAT SIMILAR
TO THE PREVIOUS ITEM. FOR SOME
FURTHER CONTEXT AND WHAT WHAT
THE STATE FUNDS TO BE USED FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AS PART OF A
LARGER FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THAT PROVIDES FREE MEALS TO
STUDENTS IN THE SUMMER AND THE
OVERARCHING PURPOSE OF THIS
FEDERAL PROGRAM IS TO ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZE MEALS IN THE SUMMER --
BECAUSE THEY'RE OTHERWISE NOT
ATTENDING SCHOOL WHERE THEY
RECEIVED.
A SUBSIDIZED MEAL DURING THE
FALL THROUGH SPRING.
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM ITSELF FUNDS
THE MEALS AND SO THE STATE
FUNDING HERE.
RATHER THAN FOR THE MEALS ARE OR
FOR ACTIVITIES THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THOSE -- MEALS SO FOR
EXAMPLE A PORTION OF THE FUNDING
WOULD BE FOR STAFF TIME TO TO
PROVIDE OUTREACH AND SUPPORT TO
LIBRARIES.
WHO WANT?
TO BECOME PART OF THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM ANOTHER PORTION OF THE
FUNDING WOULD.
PROVIDE STARTUP FUNDING FOR
LIBRARIES THAT WANT TO BECOME
SITES TO PROVIDE MEALS ANOTHER
PERSON THE FUNDING WOULD ALSO
SUPPORT I'M VERY SUMMER
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS
THAT.
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM WHEN THEY
ALSO WHEN THEY RECEIVE A FREE
MEAL AT A LIBRARY.
IN REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL WE
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
IDENTIFIED A CEILING ISSUE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
WHICH IS -- FOR A FOOD AND
SECURITY AMONG CHILDREN IN THE
STATE.
DATA SUGGESTS THAT ABOUT 19% OF
CHILDREN IN THE STATE
EXPERIENCED FOOD INSECURITY WHAT
THE RATES UP.
BIG TENDING TO BE HIGHER IN IN
THE INLAND PARTS OF THE STATE
VERSUS -- THE MORE URBAN PARTS.
I'M.
IN TERMS IT WITH THEIR ISN'T
DATA ON THE SEASONALITY OF THAT
BUT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT FOOD
SECURITY INCREASES IN THE SUMMER
WHEN STUDENTS AREN'T IN SCHOOL
AND NOT RECEIVING A FREE MEAL.
WE ALSO.
UNDERSTAND THAT BY TRYING TO
LEVERAGE MORE FUNDING THROUGH
THE SUMMER MEAL PROGRAM IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS FOR IN SECURITY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STATE LIBRARY.
IS TRYING TO LEVERAGE MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND WE ALSO
THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
APPROACH.
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT BY
FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY ON ON
FEDERATION NEW LIBRARY SITES.
THE PROPOSAL IS SOMEWHAT NARROW
IN FOCUS A WEBER IS OR JUST A
SUBSET OF PROVIDERS THAT CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE A KEY PROVIDER
IN ADDITION OF NON PROFITS IN
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES CAN SERVICE
SITES.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT --
THERE'S SOME THERE'S MANY
FACTORS THAT LIKELY EXPLAIN MY
STUDENTS MAY NOT.
RECEIVE A FREE MEAL IN THE
SUMMER AND GO TO A SITE -- ONE
OF THEM IS THAT THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH SITES ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE IN A RURAL AREA.
THERE COULD BE OTHER FACTORS TO
LIKE LACK OF AWARENESS OF THE
PROGRAM -- WE THINK BY FOCUSING
JUST ON WAIVERS AND JUST ON THE
SITES THE DEMONSTRATIONS JUST
FOCUSING ON ONE ON ONE
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND NOT AT
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM MORE
HOLISTICALLY.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IN STATE LIBRARY
TO WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHICH IS
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING THE FEDERAL PROGRAM A
IN CALIFORNIA. TO DEVELOP -- A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT
ADDRESSES SOME OF THESE ISSUES
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE PLAN WOULD
PROPOSE ALWAYS TARGET RESOURCES
IN REGIONS WHERE FOOD SECURITY
IS HIGHER.
IT WOULD INVITE ALL ENTITIES TO
OF APPLY FOR THE FUNDING NOT
JUST THE LIBRARIES FOR EXAMPLE
BUT ALSO SCHOOLS NONPROFITS
OTHER UP PROVIDERS WHO CAN SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD ALSO IDENTIFY PLANNED IT
TO TO TRACK DATA NOW COMES OVER
TIME.
NOW AS I AS I SAID IN THE BOOKS
PROGRAM GIVEN THE SHORT TIME
FRAME HERE IT PROBABLY THIS PLAN
COVER PROBABLY CAN BE DEVELOPED --
BEFORE THE MAYOR VISION AND SO
SIMILAR TO LAST PROPOSAL YOU
HAVE THE OPTION OF OF ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION COME BACK NEXT
YEAR OR CONDITIONING THE RELEASE
OF THE FUNDING ON A MORE
DEVELOPED PLAN AND NOVEMBER
HAVING A SORT OF DEAL B. C.
REVIEW.
THANK YOU WELL I ASSUME THAT IN
ADDITION TO FOOD.
IN DEALING WITH FOOD AND
SECURITY THAT THE PURPOSE HERE
IS TO TRY TO GET YOUNG PEOPLE.
INTO A LIBRARY AT A PERIOD OF
TIME WHEN THEY'RE NOT OTHERWISE
IN A K. TO TWELVE PROGRAM AND
EXPOSE THEM TO THE VARIOUS.
WONDERS OF OF OF THE LIBRARY AND
BOOKS AND READING AND OTHER
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS WITH.
A LIBRARY MAYBE YOU COULD.
THAT'S TRUE WHEN SENATOR SENATOR
MITCHELL APPROACHED US WITH THIS
IDEA LAST LAST YEAR -- IT WAS
BECAUSE THERE'S I'VE FORGOTTEN
HOW MANY BUT THERE'S SOMETHING
LIKE TWO THOUSAND OF THESE SITES
WHERE YOU CAN GET MEALS IN THE
SUMMER AND AND THE NUMBERS
FALLING A LITTLE BIT.
THE PLACES THAT HAVE BEEN.
SERVING FREE LUNCHES IN THE
SUMMER WHERE THERE'S BEEN AN
UPTICK IN ATTENDANCE HAVE BEEN
LIBRARIES.
AND SO HER THINKING WAS ALL
RIGHT IF WE CAN REDUCE SOME O
THE BARRIERS TO GETTING MORE
LIBRARIES TO DO THIS.
THEN.
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAY HAPPENS
RIGHT YOU GO THERE FOR THE MEAL
BUT YOU WALK OUT AND SIGN UP FOR
SUMMER READING OR YOU LEAVE WITH.
YOU KNOW ADD THAT'S EXTRA TO THE
SIMPLY PROVIDING OF A MEAL.
AND I'VE BEEN TO A FEW OF THESE
ONE IN ONTARIO IN EAST PALO ALTO
AND FOWLER.
AND THE COMMUNITY SEEMS TO LIKE
THE GROWERS AND FOWLER HAD
PALLETS OF FOOD SO THE FAMILIES
COULD.
YOU KNOW AND THEY HAVE AN EXPERT
AND GET A FREE MEAL WALK OUT AND
TAKE SOME FRESH FOOD HOME WITH
THEM.
ONTARIO EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO
WALKED OUT OF THE DOOR AFTER THE
MAIL WANTED TO KNOW WHERE TO
SIGN UP FOR SUMMER READING I
MEAN.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
AM I THINK I THINK SENATOR
MITCHELL WOULD BE THE FIRST
PERSON AND I WOULD ECHO WHAT.
IS THAT THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER I
MEAN ONE OUT OF FIVE KIDS I MEAN
IT'S IT'S KIND OF SHOCKING ONE
OUT OF FIVE KIDS OF GETS A FREE
OR SUBSIDIZED MIL DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR GETS ONE IN THE
SUMMER.
AND THIS IS NOT GONNA.
MAKE IT FIVE OUT OF FIVE BUT
THIS WAS AN EFFORT.
TO WHICH WHICH I THINK IS A VERY
POSITIVE ONE TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR LIBRARIES TO PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE AND FOR AN OFTEN THEIR
PARTNERS ARE AS YOU SAY LIKE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE CLOSED
AND IT'S LIKE HERE.
WE'RE HANDING YOU THE BATON FOR
THE SUMMER.
AND AT THE SAME TIME I I WOULD
NEVER THOUGHT OF THIS BUT
SENATOR MITCHELL PUT A PROVISION
IN THERE -- TOO OFFER THESE KIND
OF MICROGRAMS TO LIBRARIES TO GO
TO SOME OF THESE OTHER SITES
RIGHT IF PEOPLE COME TO THE
LIBRARY BECAUSE OF THE COOL
STUFF THERE.
WHY NOT ENCOURAGE LIBRARIES TO
GO TO THESE OTHER SITES AND SEE
IF THAT DOESN'T INCREASE THE IT
TO PRESS A TO FOR YOU ATTEMPT TO
DEAL WITH FOOD AND SECURITY
POLICE TO THE POPULATION YOU CAN
REACH AND YOU ARE ABLE TO ALSO
ADD THE EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT TO
IT.
AT THE SAME TIME IT PRECISELY
AND THEN THERE'S A YOU KNOW A
COMMAND TELLING WHAT YOU KNOW
ALREADY THERE ALL THESE STUDIES
ABOUT SUMMER SLIDE AND AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND YOU KNOW
HOW KIDS WHO DON'T -- ENGAGEIN
THAT WAY DURING THE SUMMER --
START OFF BEHIND THEIR PEERS IN
THE FALL WE'LL BE BRINGING THIS
BACK FOR A VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
I JUST HAVE TO YOU KNOW PUT MY
STRONG SUPPORT OUT THERE FOR THE
SUMMER LUNCH PROGRAM.
I'VE BEEN TO THE ONTARIO ONE AS
WELL AND AS SOMEONE WHO
ABSOLUTELY LOVES LIBRARIES I
LOVE BOOKS BUT ALSO OUR
LIBRARIES PROVIDE SO MUCH MORE
INTERNET -- FOR SOME OF OUR OR
THE INTERNET AND IT IS JUST A
WIN WIN YOU COME YOU GET A MEAL
A NUTRITIOUS MEAL OTHER FAMILIES
ARE HAPPY TO BE THERE EVERYTHING
THAT YOU JUST STATED.
AND THEY HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR LIBRARY
IT HELPS PREVENT THE SUMMER
SLIDE SO I WOULD JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT THAT
WE KEEP THIS PROGRAM GOING AS
THIS.
BUT A WOULD AGREE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THAT.
I MEAN IT'S WORTH HAVING.
LARGER DISCUSSIONS ABOUT OKAY
WHAT ARE THE OTHER PLAYERS IN
THIS AND HOW CAN WE MAKE IT FIVE
OUT OF FIVE OF THESE KIDS
GETTING A MEAL IN THE SUMMER I
AGREE OF WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN IT.
AT ANY TIME THAT IS YEAH I I
AGREE IF WE CAN EXPAND THE
PROGRAM THAT'S GREAT I JUST
DON'T.
EXPENSE OF THE THE SUMMER A
LIBRARY LUNCH PROGRAM.
AND YOUR LIBRARY DIRECTOR IN
ONTARIO IS ONE OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE ONES IN THE STATE SO.
NOW SHE IS ROCKING A AS IS YOURS
SENATOR.
THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR AB TWO TWO FIVE TO THE
MALLS.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE INTERNET
WEB.
FOR CERTAINLY SAID THAT CHAPTER
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWO
FIVE FIVE TWO OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REQUIRES THE STATE LIBRARY TO
ESTABLISH A A WEB PORTAL -- FOR
A STATE AGENCY GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
IN RECOGNITION OF THAT
LEGISLATION -- PROVIDE SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IS ONE
TIME TO DEVELOP THE WEB PORTHOLE
AS WELL AS WORK WITH STATE
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
ALL OF THE GRANT OPPORTUNITIES
UP REFLECTED ON THAT WEBSITE.
THANK YOU ILLEGAL.
THE ONE ISSUE THAT WE WOULD
RAISE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
IS THE ONGOING NEED FOR STAFFING --
FOR THE PROJECT.
THE LIMITED TERM WORKLOAD SEEMS
TO BE THAT TO FULL TIME
POSITIONS WOULD BE JUSTIFIED.
THAT WORKLOAD INCLUDES OF THE
LIBRARY GOING OUT AND REACHING
AGREEMENTS WITH VERY STATE
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY WHICH GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE AND ALSO.
TO ENSURE THAT THE WEB PORTAL
CAN -- TALK TO THEIR IN RIGHT.
INTERNET SYSTEMS AND IN ADDITION
THE OF THE LIBRARY THAT HAS
DEVELOPED THE WEB PORTAL AND
THEN THE LIBRARIAN DISSIPATES IT
WILL LIKELY HAVE TO MAKE SOME
INTERPRETIVE IMPROVEMENTS OVER
TIME.
THE BY THE SYSTEM PERHAPS
IDENTIFY EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS.
ALMOND SO THAT THAT WOULD
LIMITED TERM WORKLOAD.
SEEMS TO JUSTIFY TWO POSITIONS.
WHAT'S THE WEB PORTAL BECOMES
MORE AUTOMATED REFILL LIBRARIES
SUCCESSFUL AND AUTOMATING THAT --
THAT CONTINUE NEED TO HAVE TWO
FULL TIME POSITIONS -- WAS A
LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR TO US WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT A A A MORE
RATIONAL WAY TO DO THAT WOULD BE
TO PROVIDE LIMITED TERM FUNDING
AND THEN REVISIT THE WORKLOAD IN
A FEW YEARS WELL ONCE THE
LIBRARIES HAD AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO BUT THE WEB PORTAL ONLINE AND
AND MAKE IT OR IF IT EVER IN A
RIVER.
PREVENTS.
THE ONE ISSUE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION REYES WHEN WE
WHEN WE RAISES CONCERN WAS.
THAT OTHERS ANECDOTAL EXPERIENCE
THAT -- SIR AGENCIES THAT HAVE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS HAVE A
HARD TIME FILLING THEM OR MAY
HAVE VACANCY RATES.
AND BECAUSE OF THE TIME LINES OF
THIS PROJECT THE PROJECT AS THE
LAW REQUIRES PROJECT BETWEEN
COMPLETED BY THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT COULD
CREATE DELAYS THAT RESULT AND
PERHAPS NOT MEETING THAT
DEADLINE SO IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE TO TAKE THIS APPROACH OF
PROVIDING LIMITED TERM FUNDING.
WOULD WANT TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STATE LIBRARY
TO ENSURE THAT ANY DEADLINES ARE
ACHIEVABLE.
THANK YOU.
WELL THE JOB DESCRIPTIONS FOR
THE TO STAFFERS. TO BE DIFFERENT
ONE APPEARS TO BE.
ACTUAL WEBSITE MAINTENANCE IN
INTER OPERABILITY AND THE OTHER
IS MORE SUBSTANTIVE.
TYPE POSITION IS THAT IS THAT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING RIGHT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ONE POSITION
WOULD BE REALLY FOCUSED ON
GETTING THE STATE AGREEMENTS IN
PLACE A MEETING WITH VERY
STAKEHOLDERS -- SETTING UP THESE
AGREEMENTS ON THE SECOND -- OF
POSITION WOULD BE MORE FOCUSED
ON THE I. T. SIDE OF IT SO THE
STATE LIBRARY DISSIPATES
CONTRACTING OUT. FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE WEBSITE BUT
THEN TRAINING AND I A FULL TIME
I. T. PERSON. TO DEAL WITH THAT
DEAL WITH THE I. T. ASPECTS OF
THIS AND AGAIN MAKE ITERATIVE
IMPROVEMENTS DEBUGGED THE SYSTEM.
AND THAT AND THAT'S THE SECOND
POSITION.
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT YOU
WERE GOING TO PROBABLY NEED TO
HAVE BOTH POSITION IN ORDER TO
HAVE A FUNCTIONING -- INTERNET
WEB PORTAL THAT PROVIDES UP TO
DATE.
INFORMATION ABOUT GRANTS BUT WE
CAN WE'LL REVISIT THIS
[inaudible]
SEVEN LATER.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING IT OPEN.
HOLDING AN OPEN.
AND THAT'S IT FOR THIS ITEM
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION ITEM SIX NINE EIGHT
ZERO CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
FIRST ISSUE IS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS STUDENTS
PARENTS.
OKAY THE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT.
GEN MERRY ARE WITH FINANCE.
THANK YOU.
HE THINKING LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
DIVINE TO CALIFORNIA'S DO NEED
COMMISSION TO BURN GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK OKAY LA -- YEAH.
WRITE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
COW CAN SYSTEM IS CONTEXT FOR
THE NEXT TWO ISSUES ON THE
AGENDA REGARDING SKIN PARENTS
AND COMPETITIVE PROGRAM.
SECTIONS OF JUST DISTRIBUTED A
HANDOUT THAT WILL BE SPEAKING
FROM.
THE FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
THAT THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS
QUITE A LONG HISTORY.
THIS CREATED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AS THE STATE
CONSOLIDATED SEVERAL EXISTING
FINANCIALLY AND PROGRAMS.
IT WAS LAST SIGNIFICANTLY
RESTRUCTURED IN YEAR TWO
THOUSAND WHICH IS WHEN THE STATE
CREDIT THE ENTITLEMENT.
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WHICH WILL
DISCUSS BRIEFLY.
NEED HELP AND SPENDING TOTALS
ABOUT TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH IS A
COMBINATION OF STATE GENERAL
FUND.
AND FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THAT TENER
FOR TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT THIS IS
THE VAST MAJORITY ABOUT 95% OF
WHAT THE STUDENT COMMISSION
SPENDS AND GRANT SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT THE
SEGMENTS TO PROVIDE SOME
INSTITUTIONAL AND PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPLEMENT CAL GRANT VARIOUS
PLACE.
INCLUDING PROVIDING AID FOR SOME
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CONTENT OR HAVE EXHAUSTED THEIR
CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY.
AND IN SOME CASES PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ON TUITION ASSISTANCE
FOR **** AND ACCEPTANCE. TO HAND
OUT WE'VE SUMMARIZED HOW CAN
AWARD AMOUNTS WHICH VERY QUITE A
BIT DEPENDING ON THE WHITE.
AB AND C..
AS WELL AS THE SEGMENT
ATTENDANCE. FOR COUNTY
RECIPIENTS STUDENTS RECEIVE FULL
TUITION FEE COVERAGE AT THE
PUBLIC STATEMENTS.
AND AS THE STATE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING COLLEGE
TWICE KOKANEE RECIPIENTS TO ALSO
RECEIVE A FIXED AMOUNT FOR
TUITION AT THE PRIVATE SECONDS.
HOW CAN BE RECIPIENTS RECEIVE A
SIMILAR LEVEL OF TUITION
ASSISTANCE IN ADDITION TO A NON
TUITION AWARD CALLED THE AXIS
AWARD?
WHICH IS CURRENTLY WORTH ABOUT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
FINALLY CAO CAN'T SEE RECIPIENTS
SEE THE SMALLER WORD WORTH ABOUT
ELEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS HERE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THIS WORD IS RESERVE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE STUDENTS
PURSUING CREEK TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
PAGE THREE WITH SUMMARIZE THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR CAL
GRANT.
YOU'LL NOTICE THERE ARE NUMBER
OF CONSIDERATIONS HERE INCLUDING
NOT ONLY FINANCIAL NEEDS BUT
ALSO FACTORS SUCH AS AGE TEN OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL.
GOOD POINT AVERAGE IN SOME CASES
PROGRAM STUDY.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THOUGH
STUDENTS TO MEETING CERTAIN
INCOME AND ASSETS.
ALL OF MY FOR CONTENT.
AND THEN BEYOND THAT THERE MAIN
ROUTES THE WHICH THE MAJOR
SUPPORT.
THE FIRST IN LARGER PROGRAM IS
CALLED ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
RECENT HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES AND
TRANSFER STUDENTS UNDER AGE.
TWENTY EIGHT ARE ENTITLED TO
WORK THROUGH THIS.
AND FOR STUDENTS WHO DON'T NEED
DOESN'T HEINEMANN PROGRAM
CRITERIA STATE OFFERS A LIMITED
NUMBER CURRENTLY JUST OVER.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND COMPETITIVE
AWARDS WHICH GO TO A SMALL
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS.
FINALLY ON THE LAST PAGE OF OUR
HAND OUT WE SUMMARIZE CONTENT
SPENDING.
I PROGRAM SEGMENT AWARD TYPE AN
ELECTRONIC.
CAROL JUST CALLING ATTENTION TO
TWO MAIN POINTS THAT ARE SHADED
INSPECTOR.
FIRST TO SEE IN THE UPPER LEFT
HAND CORNER THAT FOR THE
MAJORITY WELL OVER 80% OF CAL
GRANT SPENDING GOES FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
ORDER STUDENTS FOR MORE THAN A
FEW YEARS OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL TO
HAVE FEWER OPPORTUNITIES TO
QUALIFY.
FOR FINALLY IN THE LOWER RIGHT
HAND CORNER.
YOU ALSO SEE THAT A LARGE
PROPORTION OF **** AND SPENDING
GOES TOWARD PUSH NORTH.
LITTLE RELATIVELY SMALLER SHARE
FOR NON TUITION COSTS SUCH AS
FOOD AND HOUSING.
BUT FOR MANY STUDENTS I COUNT
THE MAJORITY OF THE TOTAL COST --
OVERVIEW OF CONTENTS AND HAPPY
TO CAN COST.
WHEN IT'S IN THE GOVERNMENT?
NO OTHER THAN WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CASE ADJUSTMENTS THAT YOUR
AGENDA NOTES [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED.
CERTAINLY SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES A NEW
NON TUITION GRANT TO ASSIST CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS WHO ARE
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT A COST
OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
THESE NEW AWARDS WILL BE UP TO
SIX THOUSAND FOR CAL GRANT A AND
B. STUDENTS.
REFLECTING AN INCREASE TO THE
ACCESS A WAR THAT BE STUDENTS
ALREADY RECEIVE AND UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND FOR CAL GRANT SEE
STUDENTS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS GUIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF
TACKLING INTERGENERATIONAL
POVERTY BY SUPPORTING STUDENT
PARENTS IN THEIR PERSISTENCE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
HOW DID ANY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
HELLO. ONE OF YOUR TEN DAY
YOU'LL SEE A TABLE THAT PROVIDES
A PROFILE OF STUDENT PARENTS HER
SEEKING HOW CAN.
STUDENT PARENTS CURRENTLY
COMPRISE ABOUT 9% OF CONTENT
RECIPIENTS.
AND YOU'LL SEE AT THE TOP OF
THIS TABLE TO THE MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE SERVE THROUGH THE
COMPETITIVE WHAT PROGRAM.
THROUGH WHICH THEY BY FOR A
LIMITED NUMBER OF AWARDS.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
DOES IDENTIFIED IMPORTANT AREAS
NEED.
A GROUP OF STUDENTS WHOSE
FINANCIAL NEEDS MIGHT NOT BE
ADEQUATELY MET BY THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
THAT BEING SAID WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL AS
IT'S CURRENTLY STRUCTURED.
LISTED ON PAGE TWENTY TWO OF
YOUR DONDE ABOUT HALFWAY DOWN
THE PAGE.
THE FIRST FOUR CONCERNS IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS INDICATEDAN INTEREST
IN SIMPLIFYING THE HEALTH AND
SYSTEM.
IN STREAMLINING THE MANY
DIFFERENT RULES COVERING
ELIGIBILITY AND WHAT SITES.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
RUN COUNTER TO THESE EFFORTS BY
INTRODUCING A NEW SET OF RULES
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO ONE SUB A
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS.
WE ALSO RELATED DISTRIBUTIONAL
CONCERN.
WHETHER STUDENT HAS CHILDREN
SENT ME DOES THE FACT THEIR
FINANCIAL NEED.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO VARIOUS OTHER
FACTORS THAT SHAPE THE STUDENT'S
OVERALL NEED INCLUDING THE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ASSETS IN.
FIVE BY TARGETING ADDITIONAL AID
ACCORDING TO ONE COMPONENT OF
OVERALL NEED WE ARE CONSENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITH ME
ABOUT SOME STUDENTS WITH HIGH
OVERALL.
NEED.
WHO DO NOT HAVE CHILDREN?
WHEN WE WERE ALSO CONCERNED THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE ABOUT A
LARGE NUMBER OF STUDENTS PARENTS
WITH FINANCIAL?
THIS GOES BACK TO THE EARLIER
POINT THAT MOST STUDENTS PARENTS
ARE SIR AFTER THE COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM.
GIVEN THE COP ON COMPETITIVE
AWARDS THIS MEANS THAT ONLY A
MINORITY OF STUDENTS PARENTS
WITH FINANCIAL NEED ACTUALLY
RECEIVE A CALL.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL AID TO
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR BUT NOT
OFFERED CAL GRANT IT IS A LIMON
UNCOMPETITIVE AWARD.
IT ALSO WOULD NOT PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL AID TO STUDENTS
PARENTS WITH FINANCIAL NEED
ATTENDING THE PRIVATE
INSTITUTION. FOR THESE REASONS
WE DO RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND THAT RAISES IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS ARE ADEQUATELY
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION.
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO PURSUE
FURTHER INFORMATION ON THIS
TOPIC.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE COSTS THAT
STUDENT PRINT SPACE BUT ALSO A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
PARENTS BOTH THROUGH OUR STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM.
AND THROUGH OTHER SOCIAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS OUR WELL GIVEN
THE DELTA BETWEEN THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS FOR THE COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM IN THOSE IT ACTUALLY
RECEIVE AN AWARD MY RECOLLECTION
IS IT SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY
THOUSAND TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GIVE OR TAKE.
DO WE KNOW IF WE TOOK THIS THE
TOTAL MONEY THAT WE HAD.
HAVE.
LIED TO THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
AND WHAT AND WE APPLIED INSTEAD
TO INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE GRANTS SO MANY
GRANTS THAT WOULD ADD.
ASSESSMENT OF THE COMPETITIVE
WORDS PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSING IN THE NEXT ISSUE.
WE ESTIMATED THAT FOR EVERY
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WE PUT INTO THE COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM.
COULD RAISE THE CALIFORNIA WHERE
I ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
THAT BEING SAID AS THIS NEW
AWARDS CONVERTER NOODLES THAT
COST WOULD INCREASE OVER THE
COMING YEARS AND SO WE WOULD
NEED.
TO MORE THOUGHTFULLY MODEL THAT
IF WE WERE TO PROPOSE SHIFTING
THE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
FROM THE STUDENT PARENTS
PROPOSAL.
DIRECTLY INTO THE COMPUTER
PROGRAM SO IT'S ABOUT. FOUR
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FOR EVERY
TEN MILLION.
THAT'S RIGHT IF I WERE IF I KNEW
MATH THERE WOULDN'T BE A LAWYER
BUT AND SO WE DO WE GET TO ABOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL.
GIVE OR TAKE COMPETITIVE GRANTS
WHAT'S IF WE TOOK THE THIRTY
THREE MILLION AND WE SIMPLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE [inaudible]
GRANT.
COMPETITIVE SLOTS AVAILABLE.
MY MENTAL MATH IS NOT THAT GREAT.
I GET IT SO.
THAT'S CERTAINLY AN ISSUE AND
THEN BY DOING SO WE WOULD.
BE ABLE TO IMPACT MORE --
STUDENT PARENTS.
THAT'S RIGHT ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS JUST
BECAUSE THE LIMIT ON COMPETITIVE
AWARDS THAT WOULD LIMIT OUR
ABILITY TO BUY ADDITIONAL AID TO
THE STUDENT PARENTS WHO ARE.
ELIGIBLE FOR BUT NOT OFTEN.
LEAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR IF I MAY. ONE THING TO
BE VERY MINDFUL OF IN IN LOOKING
AT THE COMPETITIVE WARTS IS THAT
AS THOSE AWARDS A RENEWED IN THE
OUT YEARS.
THE COSTS INCREASE BEYOND THOSE
IN THE FIRST YEAR SO WHILE IT
MAY BE ROUGHLY ONE MILLION PER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY THAT
COULD BE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND TWO
MILLION THE SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
AND IF IT CAN BE VERY VOLATILE
DEPENDING ON WHICH SEGMENT THE
AWARD SHOWS UP IN A WHETHER IT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
INCREASED ROUTE REFRESH ME THE
INCREASES BECAUSE SOMETHING ELSE
IS ADDED TO THE MIX.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE ARE.
HEY LET'S SAY EVERY THOUSAND
AWARD YOU WERE TO ADD YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF THOSE AWARDS THAT WERE
NEW THE SECOND YEAR SO YOU GET A
THOUSAND NEW AWARDS EACH YEAR.
PLUS THE RENEWAL OF THAT HOUSE
AND AWARDS BUT DON'T PEOPLE DROP
OFF THE BACK END SOME DO SO YOU
SEE THE INCREASE OVER FOUR YEAR
PERIOD AND AFTER THOSE FOUR
YEARS THEN YOU WILL SEE.
MORE ABOUT A BASELINE BUT IT
CERTAINLY INCREASES FROM YOUR
ONE THREE YEAR OLD I SEE JUST ON
A START UP IDE.
RIGHT SO AFTER FOUR YEARS OF
BECOME STABLE IN YOUR FUNDING
LEVEL SHOULD BE THE SAME ABSENT.
TUITION INCREASES THAT'S CORRECT
[inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE.
SIR IS READY MEAN TO CUT YOU OUT
NOT NOT OF THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS SORT OF IMPORTANT
OF THIS EQUATION I THINK.
ARGUABLY -- JUST WANT TO SAVE
MISTER NICK EMISSIONS
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE THIS PROPOSAL BY THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZES THE THE
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS OF TODAY'S
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT -- THEIR
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM WE HAVE WAS
DESIGNED FOR A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
STUDENT AT A DIFFERENT ERA.
AND BY RECOGNIZING SPECIFICALLY
THAT THIS ONE POPULATION STUDENT
PARENTS FACES UNIQUE BURDENS AND
COSTS WE THINK THAT THAT
REPRESENTS -- AT THE VERY LEAST
A GREAT STARTING POINT. FOR THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND RESHAPING AND
EXPAND THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS OUR SEGMENT
STUDENTS AND LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
SUCH AS YOURSELVES.
HAVE YOU HAVE YOU ALL DONE I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN TALK TO
THIS BUT IF YOU OPEN AN ANALYSIS.
ON THE ISSUE THAT I WAS JUST
DISCUSSING THE INCREASING THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
GRANTS PERHAPS APPLICABLETO
STUDENT PARENTS AS OPPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE AND
WHAT THAT IMPACT WOULD BE IN
WHICH IS BETTER AND WHICH
IMPACTS MORE PEOPLE.
CERTAINLY I'M I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE A FINAL NUMBER YET AND IT
IS IMPORTANT TO LET AND
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE THAT MR
FERGUSON REYES WHICH IS THAT --
WHEN YOU WHEN WE INCREASE OR ADD
NEW AWARDS THE COMPETITOR
PROGRAM THOSE ARE FOR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS AND THEN?
YOU ASSUME THAT THERE WILL E
YOU KNOW STUDENTS RUNNING FOR A
SECOND YEAR THIRTY YOUR FOURTH
YEAR AT CETERA SO -- IN AND OF
ITSELF IF THERE WERE LIKE IF
EVERYBODY THIS ISN'T WOULDN'T
HAPPEN BUT IF EVERYBODY WENT T
COLLEGE FOR JUST ONE YEAR AND
USE THE GRANT FOR JUST ONE YEAR.
IT WOULD BE IN THE RANGE OF
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND NEW AWARDS
BUT WHAT WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
DOING IS MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
APPLY PROJECT. TO THAT TO THAT
DOES NOT OVERSTATE THE
AVAILABILITY IT WOULD LIKELY BE
SOMEWHERE AROUND THIS IS A VERY
BALLPARK ESTIMATE THIRTY
THOUSAND OR SO WHEN YOU FACTOR
IN ALL OF THE RENEWALS AND YOU
COULD I GUESS YOU COULD.
SEGMENT UP STUDENT PARENTS.
AS A CATEGORY IN THE COMPETITIVE
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS.
THEORETICALLY YES WE USE A
SCORING MATRIX FOR THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT WERE RE
LOOK AT FACTORS LIKE
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS.
FIRST GENERATION STATUS ETCETERA
TO PRIORITIZE WHICH TUDENTS GET
SOME OF THE LIMITED -- AVAILABLE
WARD SO THEORETICALLY IF THAT
WERE THE DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WE COULD INCORPORATE
ONLY INCORPORATE YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THE APPLICANT HAS
DEPENDENT CHILDREN OF THEIR
CARING FOR INTO THAT SCORING
PROCESS RIGHT A MINUTE SO IF
THAT'S THE POPULATION YOU WANT
TO TRY TO HELP.
IS IT BETTER TO DO IT THIS WAY
OR THIS WAY THAT'S THE ESSENCE
OF MY QUESTION.
I'M I'M NOT I'M NOT DISAGREEING
WITH.
THE FACT THAT THAT POPULATION --
FROM IF YOU'RE NUMERICAL
PERSPECTIVE IT APPEARS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
WOULD HELP A GREATER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN THAT POPULATION POOL
BECAUSE IT IS IT.
LIKE STATUTORILY TARGETS THE
AWARD AT STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN THAT'S A THAT'S A
QUESTION EVERY APPLICANT FOR
CALVIN ANSWERS ON THE FREE
APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL STUDENT
AID SO WE KNOW WHO THOSE ARE.
CERTAINLY INCREASING THE GENERAL
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
AWARDS WOULD HAVE THE SIDE
EFFECT OF INCREASING THE NUMBER
WERE TO GO TO THAT STUDENT
POPULATION.
BUT IT WOULD BE FAR FROM A
GUARANTEE.
I'M AS OPPOSED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
ENSURE THAT WITHOUT THOSE
DOLLARS GO TO THAT POPULATION
AND THEN A HOLLER HIGHER DOLLAR
AMOUNT.
CORRECT.
YEAH THE THE AVERAGE -- THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARD --
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
WHICH IS THE THE MAJORITY OF
COMPETITIVE CALGARY SABAEANS IS
A LITTLE UNDER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS BECAUSE IT'S THE CAL
GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD.
ADMINISTRATION ALSO WOULD BE --
SIX UP TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CABIN A. B. RECIPIENTS IN UP
TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
RETIREMENT SEE RECIPIENTS SO
YOU'D BE HAPPY BE HELPING.
A SMALLER POOL [inaudible]
BUT MORE.
THAT'S A YEAH THAT'S A FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION BY THE WAY MY
SIMPLE BRAIN LOOKED AT I GOT IT.
ANYTHING FURTHER TO LEAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
ON THAT.
OKAY.
WELL LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT%
ISSUE THEN WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER
SIX COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
FUNDING FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN NEW CAL
GRANT COMPETITIVE AWARDS
ANNUALLY AT A COST OF NINE POINT
SIX MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAM IS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR ENTITLEMENT AWARD
BUT MEET OTHER CRITERIA AS
OUTLINED BY THE COMMISSION.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
HELLO.
AS WE DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL THERE IS A COMPANY THE
AVAILABLE COMPATIBLE WHITES THAT
RESULTS IN ONLY A SMALL SHARE OF
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS. 11%
RECEIVING AN AWARD OFFER.
YOUR CHEN ON PAGE TWENTY FIVE
INCLUDE SOME DATA ON THE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WERE NOT
OFFERED WARD. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEE TOWARD THE BOTTOM OF
THE PAGE THAT THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND OF THESE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS NOT OFFERED AN AWARD.
AND THAT THEY HAD NOT VIRGIN
COMES ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
ANNUALLY.
THIS IS JUST US THAT THERE IS.
A LARGE AMOUNT OF UNMET DEMAND
FOR THIS PROGRAM AMONG STUDENTS
DEMONSTRATING A HIGH LEVEL OF
FINANCIAL NEED.
ACCORDINGLY WE THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE SPORTS
IS JUSTIFIED.
AND LEGISLATURE WISHES TO
AUGMENT FUNDING FOR CAO GRANTS
WE DO RECOMMEND PRIORITIZING
SUPPRESSED.
THANK YOU CAN DETECT QUEST.
MR BROTHER WILL FORGET YOU THIS.
THANK YOU WELL WE ARE AGAIN JUST
WANT TO SAY WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR SUPPORT FOR THE STUDENT
POPULATION -- AS WAS MENTIONED
IN THE LAST ITEM THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM DOES PRIMARILY
SERVE -- ADULT LEARNERS -- THE
PUT INPUT NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT
POPULATION WHO ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY STUDENTS
ATTENDING -- OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- I TEND TO BE AMONG
THOSE LEAST ADEQUATELY SERVED BY
OUR CURRENT FINANCIAL AID.
OUR SYSTEM AS SENATOR LEYVA IS
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH SO THE
COMMISSION HAS LONG ADVOCATED --
FOR INCREASES IN THE AMOUNT OF
AVAILABLE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
AWARDS AND AND AGAIN WE LOOK FOR
TO HELP THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP TOWARDS.
A COMPREHENSIVE REFORM OF OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT.
ALL FINANCIALLY NEEDY AND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS GET THE EIGHT
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO COMPLETE.
THANK YOU SIR SEVERAL OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
SO ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS.
HOW TO THE COLLEGE PROMISE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS TUITION WAIVERS FOR
COMMUNICORP STUDENTS AFFECT
THEIR ACCESS TO CAL GRANT OR
THEIR CAL GRANT AWARDS?
CERTAINLY SO -- WITH THE ARM THE
CULTURE PROMISE WAIVER FORMALLY
KNOWN AS THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
FEE WAIVER WHICH IS OPERATED BY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS -- AND I'M YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T OPERATE THAT PROGRAMS
AND I'M SPEAKING FROM MY
FAMILIARITY WITH IT -- AND
EITHER MY CAN JUMP IN IF I
MISSTATE ANYTHING OR DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION BUT THE COLLEGE
PROMISED FEE WAIVERS SEARCH
PRIMARILY TO WAIVE THE UNIT FEES
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHICH CAN BE I AM I BELIEVE
CLOSE TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER YEAR FOR A FULL TIME STUDENT --
V. CAL GRANT PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SINCE IT'S NOT.
TUITION THAT IS CHARGING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CALVET DOES
NOT APPLY TO THOSE UNIT FEES
RATHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE A CAL GRANT
BE ACCESS AWARD FOR NON TUITION
COSTS OKAY UP TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS PER YEAR.
OR CAL GRANT SEE WARFARE AND
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM OF A LITTLE UNDER ELEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO HAVE
FUNDED SOME ADELINE PROGRAMS IN
RECENT YEARS FUNDED BY
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT OF THE FULL TIME
COMPLETION GRANT PROVIDES I
BELIEVE UP TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON TOP OF THAT CAL GRANT
THE ACCESS AWARD. FOR STUDENTS
ALREADY GETTING THAT GRAHAM BE
ACCESS WARD TO POTENTIALLY THEY
COULD RECEIVE BOTH.
CORRECT OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ARE CAL GRANT UNTIL GRANT AWARDS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS ATTENDING
HALF OR LESS THAN HALF TIME -- I
BELIEVE THE THE CAL GRANT IS
AVAILABLE STUDENTS ATTENDING
HALFTIME OR MORE SO THAT IS SIX
SEMESTER UNITS OR MORE -- PER
TURN THE PROGRAM I BELIEVE MAY
BE THE SAME IF I'M REMEMBERING
CORRECTLY.
AND HAS FROM THE IDEA THERE'S A
TON OF PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO CAN ANSWER THIS BUT OKAY ALL
IN FAVOR RIGHT.
VERY GOOD OKAY THANK YOU ONE
MORE.
HOW MANY OF THE UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS?
OVER TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
WITHIN THE COMMITTED CAL GRANT
PROGRAM OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPLICANTS.
WHY DO NOT HAVE THAT INFORMATION
ON ME I'M SORRY I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO GET THAT ALREADY IN THAT FORM
IT WOULD BE VERY VERY YEAH WE
CAN GET THAT FOR YOU AND I AM
SURE WE ALREADY HAVE IT I JUST
DON'T HAPPEN TO HAVE IT ON ME?
IT'S POSSIBLE AND BEING TESTED
THAT RIGHT NOW MY LONG STANDING
FEAR OF CHECKING MY PHONE WHEN
TESTIFYING -- I WILL BE LOOKING
AT BUT I KNOW THAT APPROXIMATELY
7275% OF RECIPIENTS OF THE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO MY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE -- TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN WILL HOLD SIX SIX
OPEN OBVIOUSLY.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN RED DELIVERY
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES SIX
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE SECOND YEAR
OF PROJECTS COSTS FOR THE
COMMISSION'S GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION PROJET.
FINANCE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE PROJECT REGULARLY AND
CONSIDER THE PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY ON TIME AND ON BUDGET
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
FEEL LIKE I'M BACK IN BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE [inaudible]
FOUR THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
THE STATE NEEDS IS CURRENTLY IN
ITS FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTING
THAT CAN'T DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT AND BASE
NERF YOU THIS PROJECT APPEARS TO
BE GENERALLY ON SCHEDULE AND
WITHIN BUDGET.
THIS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IS ALSO PROVIDING
INDEPENDENT PROJECT OVERSIGHT
AND IN THEIR MONTHLY OVERSIGHT
REPORTS OF GENERALLY PROVIDED
THIS CHECK THE QUICKPOSITIVE
RATINGS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE A SECONDARY PROJECT
FUNDING FOR THE SITE TO PROJECT.
THIS YOU NEED COMMISSION IS
INDICATED THAT THEY WILL LIKELY
COMPLETE THIS PROJECT DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR.
WHAT SHOULD PROVIDE LEGISLATURE
WITH ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
PRIDE RECITE AS PART OF NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU?
NO I KNOW THERE'S A NEW
ESTIMATED COMPLETION DATE OF
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE REFRESH
MY RECOLLECTION SINCE THIS IS A
A NEW BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ME
DOES. TOO OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
MEMBERS GET A PERIODIC UPDATE ON
THE STATUS OF THIS PROJECT.
US SO WE HAVEN'T PROVIDED A
PERIODIC UPDATE TO STAFF MEMBERS
OF THE PROJECT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
CONTINUES TO THEIR MONTHLY
UPDATES ON THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECT THROUGH.
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT THEY
VALIDATE.
I SEE AND WE HAVE ACCESS IS THE
COMMITTEE YES IT'S PROBABLY
ONLINE AVAILABLE TO ALL.
WILL MOTHER NATURE THE OKAY
ANYTHING ON THIS MISTER RIGHT
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR THIS PROJECT -- THESE
UPGRADES ARE CRUCIAL TO CONTINUE
TO ADMINISTER FINANCIALLY
EFFECTIVELY TO OUR STUDENTS --
IF THERE ARE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER GRINNED REMAINS IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY OF THOSE
AS WELL -- JUST JUST LET US KNOW
IF WE I LOVE GREEN LIGHT SO JUST
LET US KNOW IF WE START GETTING
YELLOWS OKAY [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
QUESTION.
SEVEN OKAY LET'S DO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT STATE OPERATIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND IS ON GOING AND THREE
PERMANENT POSITIONS. TO SUPPORT
THE COMMISSION'S OPERATIONS ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS FOR SYSTEM
UPDATES TO THE CURRENT GRANT --
EVERY SYSTEM TO ACCOUNT FOR
RECENTLY ENACTED LEGISLATION
EXPANDING CAL GRANT B. AND
CHAFEE GRANT ELIGIBILITY FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
OF THE THREE POSITIONS TO
ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM
ANALYST. TO SHOW SUPPORT
DIVISION AND ONE OFFICE
TECHNICIAN WILL BE PROVIDED TO
SUPPORT THE EXECUTIVE STAFF OF
THE COMMISSION HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HELLO.
PROPOSALS REGARDING STATE
OPERATIONS ARE BOARDED OUT ON
PAGE THIRTY ONE IF YOUR AGENDA
FINAL PAGE.
REGARDING THE FIRST PROPOSAL
PROVIDE ONE TIME FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT NEW PHOSPHATE
ELIGIBILITY RULES.
AND THE THIRD PROPOSAL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL EXECUTIVE OFFICE
SUPPORT.
OUR OFFICE IS NO CONCERNS.
WE WILL BRIEFLY COMMENT ON THE
SECOND PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ON GOING INTO
POSITIONS FOR INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT.
THE STUDENT COMMISSION IS
INDICATED THAT THE INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT UNIT WHICH PROVIDES
TRAINING AND SUPPORT TO HIGH
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND COLLEGE
FINANCIAL AID ADMINISTRATORS.
HAS EXPERIENCE EXTENSION
INCREASES IN WORKLOAD OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
BASED ARE A FEW WE THINK THAT
ADDING ONE ADDITIONAL POSITION
TO DISCONNECT WOULD.
REDUCE THE OVERTIME THAT THEIR
EXISTING STAFF ARE WORKING AND
ALLOW IT TO MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS EXPLAINED
THAT IMPOSING TWO POSITIONS
RATHER THAN ONE THE INTENT ALLOW
THIS UNIT TO FIGHT HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE. TO HEAR WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT IF THAT IS A
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY IN THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO PROVE
BOTH POSITIONS.
IT MAY ALSO WISH TO CONSIDER
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
THE STATE NEED PERMISSION TO
REPORT ON THE UNITS HAVE
COMMITTEES.
JUST TO ENSURE THAT THE
AUGMENTATION IS HAVING CONTENT
THE FACT.
THANK YOU [inaudible] TO RUN.
JUST WANNA SAY ONCE AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT -- MULTIPLE ANALYSES
THAT WE HAVE DONE IT INDICATED A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING IN
OUR AGENCY. ONE WAY TO LOOK AT
IT IS WE DON'T JUST ADMINISTER
STATE FINANCIALLY WE ARE VERY
MUCH A CUSTOMER SERVICE AGENCY.
OUR CUSTOMERS INCLUDE NOT JUST
THE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS RECEIVING
FINANCIAL AID FROM A STATE WIDE.
BY OVER THREE HUNDRED COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS
THOUSANDS OF HIGH SCHOOL SO --
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO ENABLE
TO PERFORM THAT CUSTOMER SERVICE
MISSION -- WE'VE REQUESTED AND
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTED
THIS STOPPING AUGMENTATION.
BIRD REVISITING THIS LOTUS OPENS
OUR LIVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OUTSTANDING PRESENTATION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
PROBABLY NEVER SEEN SEE A
BUDGETS OF ONE COMMITTEE HEARING
THIS SURE.
YEAH WHATEVER [inaudible]
WORK.
BUT MAYBE I SPOKE TOO SOON.
STEP ON DOWN I DON'T.
KNOW.
HERE THE GROUND RULES.
I DON'T GENERALLY SET TIME
LIMITS -- BUT LOOK AROUND YOU.
AND THE TRY TO KEEP COMMENTS
BRIEF.
IF YOU CAN YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBER.
AND CHAIR THINKING SO MUCH
SAMANTHA SAYING WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
OUR STUDENT LEADERS WHO ARE
LEADING THE FIX FINANCIAL AID
CAMPAIGN -- WE SUPPORT REFORMS
TO THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM THAT
WERE MORE REMOVED ELEVATE
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS COVERS THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE SUMMER
COURSES.
AND IT IS ME BASS PC FINANCIAL
FIXING FINANCIAL AID ASONE SIDE
OF THE COIN OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY ON THE OTHER SIDE --
IS THE MASSIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
CRISIS THAT'S COMING FORWARD AND
SO WE SEE THAT FIXING FINANCIAL
AID WILL ALSO MAKE AN IMPACT ON
THAT -- CRISIS AND SO WE THINK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK AND
LOOKING INTO THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR BREVITY
YES SIR.
THIS RESPONSE OF THE CHILL OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND ALSO
REPRESENTING OUR YOUTH
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK.
LOOK OF CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH LAW THAT
ORGANIZATION WE'RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
TO FIND A AN INCENTIVE SERVICE
PROGRAM FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AS WE KNOW IT THIS
WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL CAL GRANT.
AS WE KNOW THEY'RE SENDING A
DOCTOR -- ON DOCUMENTS STUDENTS
THAT ARE COMING TO OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS WHICH IS ESTIMATED AT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND A DOCUMENT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS -- ARE
GRADUATED FROM CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLS ARE GONNA BE DRASTICALLY
I'M NOT BE ABLE TO FINANCE THEIR
EDUCATION AS THE CURRENT ON A
DOCUMENT A POPULATION OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SO WE WOULD ASK FOR THE THE ON
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO
THAT -- AND THEN -- SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL OF THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH IT WOULD BE AB FIVE FORTY
BY SOMEONE IN THE MONTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES SIR I GET AFTERNOON CHAIR
ROTH SENATOR LEYVA I'M JEFF
BRUNNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR WORK IN THIS SESSION TO
ADVANCE A MORE AFFORDABLE PATH.
A DEGREE FOR OUR STUDENTS -- AND
WE HOPE THAT IN WORKING WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL FOCUS ANY ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FINANCIALLY
PROGRAMS ON OUR MOST FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS.
HOPING -- SERVE MORE OF THE
UNFUNDED WORK IN THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT POOL AS WELL AS
HELPING ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT
GROWING NON TUITION COSTS THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE FACING
PARTICULARLY AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AS WELL AS LOOKING AT HOW W CAN
FACILITATE SUMMER ENROLLMENT TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS GRADUATE ON
TIME IN A MORE AFFORDABLE
FASHION.
ON BEHALF OF OUR CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION I'M THAT WE HELP
FACILITATE WE WOULD ECHO WHAT
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM CHIRLA JUST
SPOKE UP IN REGARDS TO A SERVICE
AND SENATE GRANT PROGRAM. TO
HELP OFFSET THEIR IN ELIGIBILITY
FOR FEDERAL AIDAND PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS AND THEN
FINALLY ON THE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT FILERS
ARE CURRENTLY BY STATUTE PLACED
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE COMPETITIVE
LIST REGARDLESS OF THEIR
FINANCIAL NEED OR THEIR ACADEMIC
MERIT -- GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
STILL GOING ON FUNDED WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU LOOK TO DELETE THAT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE SO THAT THEY
CAN COMPETE FOR AN AWARD ON THE
SAME BASIS AS THEIR PEERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON LARA'S ABA CUBITS
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS WE ARE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT NEEDY
STUDENT PARENTS BUT WE BELIEVE A
MORE AFFECTED TARGET EFFECTIVE
TARGETED SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING
UNMET NEED WOULD BE TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF ANNUALLY AVAILABLE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS AS HAS
BEEN.
SUGGESTED TODAY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT ELIGIBLE STUDENT
PARENTS 71% OF APPLICANTS DO NOT
RECEIVE ONE SIMPLY BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH FOR AVAILABLE.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION PROPOSED
INSTEAD FIND OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
MORE NEW COMPETITIVE AWARDS
ALMOST TRIPLING THE CURRENT
AMOUNT.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
STATE FINANCIAL AID TO MANY OF
THE OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS.
EACH YEAR MANY OF WHOM ARE
PARENTS AND MOST OF WHOM ARE
VERY LOW INCOME WHO DO NOT
RECEIVE A CAL GRANT BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH FOR AVAILABLE.
I'LL ALSO ADD THAT WE SUPPORT
INCREASING THE SIZE OF THE CAL
GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD THAT HELPS
THE LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS COVER
TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS INCLUDING
CRITICAL LIVING EXPENSES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO HELP
NEW NEEDY CALIFORNIANS AT THE
FINANCIALLY THEY NEED TO ACCESS
AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING BE I'VE READ SO THE
CALIFORNIA I'D COALITION OUR
COALITION IS THE PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM WITH AN EMPHASIS ON TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
SUPPORTING -- TO SUPPORT SELF
SUPPORTING A FAMILY SUPPORTING
STUDENTS.
I WAS UP IN THAT DIRECTION WE
ARE ALSO SUPPORT OF A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE TO THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
THE ACT WITH THE WORDS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR AUTHOR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS-BRANDON RAKEEM I'M A SECOND YEAR
UCLA AND A FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN.
I'M AFTER IMMIGRATING FROM IRAN
MY PARENTS CAME TO UCLA AND IT
WAS REALLY AN IMPORTANT PART IN.
HOW THEY WERE ABLE TO SUCCEED
WITH THE AMERICAN DREAM?
MY MOM ALWAYS TELLS ME HOW WHEN
SHE WENT YOU SILLY TUITION WAS
ONLY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A
QUARTER.
AND TODAY IT'S OBVIOUSLY SO MUCH
MORE THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PREVIOUS SUPPORT FOR FUNDING THE
UC AND I'M PROVIDING FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THE SUMMER CAL
GRANT BUT I CAN'T URGE YOU
ENOUGH. TO CONTINUE DOING THAT
BECAUSE ACCESSIBILITY IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
THE UC PROVIDES TO SO MANY
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I HOPE THEY'LL CONTINUE INTO
THE FUTURE SO THANK YOU AND I
YIELD THE REST OF MY GOOD
AFTERNOON CENTER OFF ON THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERETODAY AND
MEMBERS OF ME AS WELL THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO EVERYTHING
BRANDON SAID I'M HE MENTIONED
TUITION HIKES AND WHILE THE LAST
YEAR'S TUITION HIKE WAS HELD OFF.
I WANNA TALK ABOUT --
ACCESSIBILITY FOR ALL STUDENTS
RATHER INVESTING IS OUR ME
HAVING STUDENTS INVEST IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
I BELIEVE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
BE INVESTING IN THE STUDENTS.
WITH THE CALVET UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BEING ARGUABLY THE
PREMIER PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
THE NATION THIS TITLE SHOULD NOT
BE EARNED BASED ON ACADEMICS
ALONE.
RATHER SERVICES THE UNIVERSITY
PROVIDES FOR THE STUDENTS AS
WELL SO THIS MEANS SERVICES LIKE
THAT WOULD BE THE METAL SERVICES
RIGHT NOW IF I TRIED GETTING A
APPOINTMENT WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR IT WOULD
TAKE
A MONTH TO TWO MONTHS -- TO
SCHEDULE THAT JUST BECAUSE OF
HOW UNDERSTAFFED WE ARE AT UCLA.
SOME CLASSROOMS ARE FILLED TO
THE BRIM WE HAVE TO SIT ON THE
GROUND AND IN SOME CASES AND
THAT'S EVEN WORSE IN THE STEM
FIELDS -- FOR NORTH CAMPUS --
SOUTH CAMPUS MAJORS EXCUSE ME SO
WHILE I MAY BE IN HUMANITIES.
STUDENTS IN CS LECTURES HAPPENS
ON THE GROUND AND SOMETIMES
THERE'S NO SEATS ON THE GROUND
AS WELL AS THEY HAVE TO STAND
AND TAKE NOTES STANDING.
SO -- I AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HOWEVER WE
STILL BELIEVE THAT MORE
INVESTMENT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS NOT ONLY.
HOW OF ACCESSIBILITY TO THE UC
SYSTEM BUT ONCE THEY GET THERE
HAVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
SUCCEED IN IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU YES SIR?
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR AUTUMN
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE -- ARE
YOU POLLUTION FROM A UC IRVINE
I'M A SENIOR I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE SUMMER CAL GRANTS --
SO I THINK SUMMER TARGETS TO BE
VERY BENEFICIAL FOR YOU SEE
IRVINE -- IN THIS YOU SEE IN
GENERAL AS YOU ON THOUGH UC
IRVINE WAS -- CAME UNDER HEAVY
CRITICISM FOR RESCINDING FIVE
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR
UNDERGRADUATES I'M NEVER INCOME
ME.
PRIMARILY DUE TO OVERCROWDING --
IN HAVING SUMMER TALK GRANTS
WILL WILL ALLOW CURRENT YOU SEE
STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE IN A MORE
REASONABLE MANNER AND MORE
AFFORDABLE MANNER.
AND ALLOW -- MORE.
WHAT QUALIFIED HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE TRANSFERS IN APPLICANTS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE WORLD
CLASS EDUCATION AT UC OFFERS?
THANKS THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA REMEMBER
HALF THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM.
INCLUDE STREAMLINING.
CAL GRANT AND BE PROVIDING EXTRA
FUNDING FOR THE ACCESS TO WORK
FOR STUDENTS AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN BE
ABOUT ENDING.
I'M WE ALSO SUPPORT RETURNING TO
A FUNDING FORMULA FOR STUDENTS
WHO CHOOSE THE PRIVATE NOT FOR
PROFIT SECTOR.
SO THEY CAN ALSO GRADUATE WITH
LITTLE DEBT -- INCLUDING SUMMER
SCHOOL FUNDING AS WELL SYSTEMS
CAN GRADUATE ON TIME.
PORTER UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
ENSURING THAT WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH A THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ROTH CENTER
LEYVA MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST ONE
ECHO SOMUCH OF HIS THOUGHTS OF
FROM TKS CAMPAIGN AND CALIFORNIA
AS COALITION -- WE SUPPORT OF
BOTH OF FINANCIALLY.
AS DOWN PAYMENTS TOWARDS THE
MUCH LARGER GOAL IN FINANCIALLY
WHICH IS TO INCREASE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY MORE BROADLY.
ALLOW MORE STUDENTS TO ACCESS
FINANCIAL AID AND INCREASED
ACCESS AWARD FOR ALL STUDENTS
WITH FINANCIALLY.
FINANCIAL NEED SECOND ARE WE ASK
YOU JUST WERE SB TWO NINETY ONE
AND IT'S TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST.
THE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM.
AND LASTLY WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKED A POLICY
SOLUTION TO INCREASE OUR FASTING
CALIFORNIA DREAM AT COMPLETION
RATE STATEWIDE CURRENTLY WE ARE
SENIORS ONLY COMPLETED AT ABOUT.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT IN THE NATION
SO WE REALLY NEED.
TO LOOK FOR A SOLUTION TO
INCREASE THOSE RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN -- MY NAME SO I MOUNT
A LOT MAN I'M FROM THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA MOST TO UNDERGRAD
STUDENT CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN
UNIVERSITY.
AND I'VE COME HERE TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT ARE A LOT OF TO ME BUT IF
YOU TO CALDERON A. M. THAT'S
ADMINISTERED BY C. SOCK.
THE I'M THRILLED IMPACT OF THE
CAGR HAS HAD ON ME IS LIFE
CHANGING -- FULL CONSIDERATION
IN CONTEMPLATION I SET FORTH TO
ATTEND COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
SOMETHING I WOULD HAVE NEVER --
ATTEMPTED WITHOUT CAL GRANT HEY.
AND THIS IS THE LAST WEEK OF MY
FIRST SEMESTER.
AND IT I FIRMLY BELIEVE IT IS
THE BEST DECISION I HAVE MADE
THIS THING.
AND UPON COMBINATION IN SPRING
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'LL BE
THAT MUCH CLOSER TO A FINANCIAL
FREEDOM.
AND ECONOMIC STABILITY AND WILL
BE ABLE TO GIVE THE SOCIETY BY
BECOMING A PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF
IT AND ALL THE MEANWHILE
CONTINUING THIS.
SUCCESSFUL LOOP FOR ALL
GENERATIONS AFTER MYSELF.
I HOPE MY STORY RESONATES WITH
ME WITH YOU AND TO KEEP ALL CAL
GRANTS ACTIVE AS A READILY
AVAILABLE RESOURCE. FOR ALL
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OF
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME FOR WITHOUT IT
OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE LOST AND
AND YOUR STORIES OF SUCCESSFUL
ARISE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR COMING [inaudible]
YES SIR.
YOU ARE GETTING GOLD STARS FOR
BREVITY SO.
IT UP THAT'S PRESSURE.
ALEX CRAZY ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENT OVER
EIGHTY NOT PROFIT.
AS IN THE STATES SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA WITH BRENT.
I'M JUST ONE OF THANK YOU CHAIR
AT AND CENTER LEYVA. FOR THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION.
IN HALF AN INCH LABOR FORM THIS
YEAR.
I'M JUST A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS ON
ISSUES FIVE AND SIX WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS THAT.
SERVE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
WOULD BENEFIT FROM AN INCREASE
IN THE COMPETITIVE PAUL.
ON THE STUDENT PARENT ISSUE.
WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENT PARENT CALGARY SIPPING
IT'S CURRENTLY IN OUR SYSTEM
OVER TO OUR FIFTY WHICH ARE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE.
TENDING INSTITUTIONS IN THAT
AREA.
THEY WOULD.
PROPOSAL NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AID I AND IF THAT
GOES WHERE WE'D LIKE TO SEE THEM
TREATED EQUITABLY.
I IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS -- BUT
AGAIN WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION AND AS THE
STUDENTS JUST MENTIONED WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE I'M SORRY -- HOCKEY
MENTION WE LIKE TO SEE A RETURN
TO A FUNDING FORMULA TO ENSURE
STABILITY AND PREDICTABILITY IN
THE AWARD LEVEL. FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR INSTITUTIONS WHERE
AS WE'VE BEEN SETTING IT IN
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS FOR ABOUT
EIGHTEEN YEARS NOW.
THANK YOU.
AFTER LEGISLATORS MY NAME IS
COMMON BUT NOT ABLE TO COOK OR
ANIMAL FOR THAT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA.
ALSO WE OBSERVE UNIVERSITY.
COLUSA FOR BETTY.
I MEAN JUST STATE MY SUPPORT FOR
SOME OF COMPOUND SELECTED BANK
CENTER TO DROP FOR HAVING THAT
EFFORT.
THE REASON WHY WE BELIEVE IN
SOME COVERS BECAUSE FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
KNOW THAT THE UC'S.
AS ATHLETES AND ROLLING OVER
SUMMER WHEREAS THE CCR SIX WAS
IN ROME OR SUMMER.
AND I KNOW THAT THROUGH THIS YOU
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT OVER A
ROLE WITHIN HOUSE WHICH ARE NOT
ABLE TO GRADUATE ON TIME YEAH WE
HAVE THIS THREE MONTH CARRIED
OVER SUMMER.
WHERE STUDENTS COULD TAKE
CLASSES AND WITH THESE PASS
ACTUALLY?
THAT'S WHAT IT IS THAT MY
SUPPORT FOR SOME CAL GRANT AND
HOPE THIS COMMITTEE WOULD PUSH.
FOR PROBLEMS BY THE WITHIN THE
STATE BUDGET.
THANKS FOR COMING SIR OKAY MA'AM
HI MY NAME'S ALYSSA OTIS GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M A THIRD YEAR
TRANSFER AT UC SANTA BARBARA I'M
ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT.
THE CAL GRANT SUMMER CAL GRANTS
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU RICHARD
ROTH FOR ADVOCATING FOR THEM.
THANK YOU SEE DATA DOES SHOW
THAT EVERY CORNER I STUDENTS
THESE PAST FOUR YEARS THEY LOSE
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
EARNINGS.
AND A SUMMER CAL GRANT WOULD
REALLY HELP I KNOW PERSONALLY I
HAD A MAJOR SURGERY AND IF IT
WEREN'T FOR SUMMER SCHOOL I
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE ON TRACK
TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
SO I KNOW PERSONALLY HOW MUCH
SUMMER SCHOOL IS REALLY
BENEFICIAL IF IT'S MORE
AFFORDABLE.
AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO PUSH OR THE FUNDING FOR
THE SUMMER CAL GRANTS THANK YOU.
LET'S TRY TO GET IT.
YES MA'AM.
I'M NOT SO GOOD AFTERNOON
LEGISLATORS -- MY NAME VERONICA
AND JOHNNY I'M OF FIRST CAN
TRANSFER STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA FROM BIGGER SO COLLEGE --
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SENATOR
ROSS -- PUSH TO MAKE FUNDING FOR
CAL GRANTS UNTIL SUMMER CAL
GRANTS AVAILABLE ON THE BUDGET
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORT --
SO A STUDY DONE BY NERDWALLET
SHOWS THAT IF A STUDENT STAYS
JUST EVEN TWO YEARS EXTRA -- AT
UNIVERSITY THAT THEY'LL LOSE
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN LIFETIME EARNINGS --
SO SUMMER CAL GRANTS REALLY
WOULD BE.
JUST SO NECESSARY IN CRUCIAL TO
HELP.
STUDENTS MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE ON TIME AND THEN MAKE
WAY FOR THE FELLOW INCOMING.
STUDENTS -- LAST YEAR YOU SEE
APPLICATIONS WERE LIKE THE
HIGHEST EVER IN HISTORY THEY
BROKE ALL RECORDS AS GIRLS AND
THEN AGAIN -- BUT LIKELY -- I
DID AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
THINGS EASIER FOR THOSE COMING
AFTER US TO SET THE STAGE FOR A
MORE PROSPEROUS FUTURE IN
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL BRADY AND
FROM UC SANTA BARBARA AND I'M A
SOCIOLOGY MAJOR.
AND ALSO YOU TO STATE MY SUPPORT
FOR SUMMER CALTRANS I LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR ROCK RISK YOU'RE
HEADING THAT.
SO YOU SEE DATA SHOWS THAT 50%
OF RUSSIAN RATIONS BROWN HOW
GRANT RECIPIENTS DO NOT GRADUATE
IN FOUR YEARS.
AND SUMMER CAL GRANT WILL HELP
THE STATE STUDENTS LIKE. FOR LOW
COME FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS WORK MULTIPLE JOBS YOU
STRUGGLE EVERYDAY TO BE
FINANCIALLY SECURE AT UNIVERSITY
TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
I BELIEVE GRADUATING IN FOUR
YEARS SHOULD NOT BE BARRED BY
HOW MUCH MONEY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR COMING YES SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEXA RODRIGUEZ
I'M A THIRTY YEAR CULTURAL
ANTHROPOLOGY STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA.
I'M HERE TO STATE MY SUPPORT FOR
THE SUMMER SO CAL GRANT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE SILICON SUMMER
CAL GRANT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
CONTINUOUSLY ASKED FOR PUBLIC
COLLEGES TO TAKE ON MORE
STUDENTS HAS FAILED TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING.
AS A RESULT OF CLASSES ARE OVER
IN BOLD AND IMPACTED SO STUDENTS
CANNOT TAKE CLASSES THAN.
EIGHT I RECENTLY SPOKE TO ONE OF
MY ADVISORS AND THAT AND THEY
TOLD ME DESPITE HAVING ONLY FIVE
CLASSES LEFT TO TAKE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR THERE WAS A
STRONG CHANCE THAT I WOULD NOT
GRADUATE ON TIME WITHOUT SUMMER.
CLASSES A SUMMER CAL GRANT WOULD
DEEPLY HELP A STUDENT SUCH AS
MYSELF A AND GRADUATING ON TIME
AND PURSUING THEIR CAREERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
BY THE WAY BUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
EVERYTHING'S A TEAM EFFORT
APPEARS SO WILL BE THANK A LOT
OF PEOPLE THANK YOU FOR COMING --
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS HI MY
NAME'S CAM UP HERE TODAY AS A
FIRST YEAR STUDENT AT SANTA
BARBARA.
AND I'M ALSO A PART OF THE
COALITION FOR A BABY SEAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR RICHARD ROTH
FOR HELPING US AND REALLY TRYING
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
AND SO NOW. FORTY YEARS AGO THEY
ARE CALIFORNIA SPENT TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND HE IS.
AND NOW FOUR YEARS LATER THAT
NUMBER HAS DECREASED EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND IN THE TWO QUARTERS I'VE
BEEN AT UCSD I'VE ALREADY SEEN
THE CONSEQUENCES.
WE'RE CONSTANTLY -- WORRIED AND
CAN'T GET THE CLASSES THAT WE
NEED IN ORDER TO GRADUATE AND WE
CAN'T AFFORD THE CLASSES -- THAT
WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE OVER THE
SUMMER.
AND SO THIS IS WHY WE'RE ASKING
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE BUDGET IN
ORDER. TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO VISIT US OKAY LET'S START
OVER HERE SIR YES.
AUGUST -- GOOD EVENING OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SHORT RIGHT
THANK.
YOU FOR THE THEY SO MUCH WORSE I
MY NAME IS ALEX AND I'M A SENIOR
AT UCSB I'M ALSO A COMMUNICATION --
FOR FOR YOU SEE SB -- LOBBY
COURSE I'M HERE -- TO TO TALK
ABOUT THE SUMMER CAL GRANT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME IT'S WORKING I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS AND
WE'RE HERE HERE FOR OF PUSH FOR
SOME CAL GRANT FUNDING IN THE
STATE BUDGET CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO EXPERIENCE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATE DEFICIT
BY IT THAT YOU HAVE. THIRTY AND
A SOME A SOME ACOG IT WOULD HELP
THESE STUDENTS GUY BUDGET BUSTER --
I MYSELF OKAY OF CHANCES HIDDEN
TCS BE AND I'VE BEEN UNFORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE A PART OF THIS
PROGRAM CALL TRANSFER SOME A
STAR PROGRAM WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
PAY FOR MY FIRST ON A SUMMER
SESSION.
SO I WAS ABLE TO TAKE THE A
PREREQUISITE COURSES FOR MY
SCIENCE PSYCHOLOGY MAJOR.
SO AS I STARTED FOR FALL QUARTER
OF QUARTER I WAS ACTUALLY A FULL
MAJOR STATUS WHICH I CAN TAKE
UPPER DIVISION CLASSES WHERE IS
THE MY FELOW OTHERS A CHANCE
FOR STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND THEN THERE WAS.
A STARTING FRESH FROM FALL AND
AND THEY OFTEN TIMES THEY GET TO
STAY A ONE OR TWO MORE QUARTER
AFTER TWO YEARS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T.
THEY DIDN'T GET TO A COMPLETE
THEIR UPPER DIVISION CLASSES SO
YOU ARE YOUR PUSH FOR SOMEONE
CAL GRANT WITH WITH WITH --
BENEFICIAL FOR A LOT OF STUDENTS
AND ALSO A SPECIFIC REQUEST.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR COMING YES
SIR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRIAN IRAN AND I AM A SECOND
YEAR HISTORY MAJOR AT UC SANTA
BARBARA I'M HERE TO STATE MY
SUPPORT FOR SUMMER CAL GRANT AND
LIKE TO STE -- THANK SENATOR
RICHARD ROTH FOR SUPPORTING THEM --
RECENT PELL GRANT EXTENSIONS
COUPLED WITH -- INSTITUTIONAL
GRANTS DO NOT ACTUALLY -- COVER
SUMMER TUITION AND FEES WHEREAS
A SUMMER CAL GRANT WOULD
ACTUALLY HELP TO YOU ON THE
COVER THESE COSTS AND IT
ACTUALLY HELP ON THE STATE'S
GRADUATE FASTER.
I MYSELF WOULD HAVE TO PAY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT OF POCKET
JUST FOR ONE SESSION AT UC SANTA
BARBARA ENDING A FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME STUDENT
THAT IS JUST NOT POSSIBLE FOR ME
AND MY PARENTS AND SO HAVING A
SUMMER CAL GRANT WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP OUT A LOT.
THAT'S WHY I AM ASKING -- TO
THERE ARE THIS COMMITTEE TO
ALLOCATE MONEY IN THE STATE
BUDGET FOR SUMMER CAL GRANT.
YES -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMBER WALKER IN THE FIFTH YEAR
UC SANTA BARBARA I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SUMMER CAL GRANTS
NO LIKE TO THINK SENATOR RICHARD
ROTH AND OTHERS FOR SPEARHEADING
THEM -- DATA SHOWS A 55% OF THE
FIRST GENERATION BLACK PROGRAM
RECIPIENTS IN ROAD IN THE UC
SYSTEM DID NOT GRADUATE ON TIME --
IN THE SUMMER CONGRESS WOULD
HELP THE STUDENTS GRADUATE
FASTER.
AS A FIRST GENERATION BLACK
STUDENT COMING FROM A BACKGROUND
OF FOSTER CARE AND URBAN LIVING
I HAVE LITTLE TO NO GUIDANCE ON
ADVOCATE A HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
I RELIED HEAVILY ON SUMMER
SCHOOL AS A MEANS TO KEEP UP
WITH MY CLASS -- AFTER WORKING
TWO JOBS ALSO MOST ON ABLE TO
FUND SCHOOL ON TOP OF LIVING
EXPENSES AND WAS CONSEQUENTIALLY
DROP FROM A SUMMER COURSES.
NOW AS A FIFTH YEAR I CAN ATTEST
THAT SUMMER FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
WILL INDEED EIGHT OUR TIME WE
ECONOMIC SUCCESS -- I BELIEVE
THAT FUNDED SUMMARY CAL GRANTS
FROM OF THE STATE BUDGET IS A
VITAL STEP AND RENDERING THAT
SUPPORT.
THANKS AGAIN AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANKS FOR
COMING YES SIR.
YOUR SENATOR OFTEN HONORABLE
LEGISLATORS MY NAME IS JONATHAN
WE BOW AND I AM A THIRTY YEAR
HISTORY MAJOR AND THE IRANIANS.
STUDIES MINOR AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA.
SO I CAME HERE TO THE STATE
CAPITOL WITH A DOES OF MY A
DOZEN OF MY FELLOW YOU SEE SB.
SINCE OUR TOGETHER TRAVEL OVER
FOUR HUNDRED MILES THROUGH THE
NIGHT TO MAKE IT HERE BEFORE YOU.
THIS AFTERNOON AND SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF SUPPORTING SUMMER CAL
GRANT.
SO I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WHY I
BELIEVE IT IS IN CALIFORNIA'S
INTEREST TO SUPPORT HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGH THIS.
BUDGET.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW WE'RE LIVING
IN A RAPIDLY CHANGING WORLD WORK
TODAY A COLLEGE DEGREE IS NOW
THE EQUIVALENT OF WHAT A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
WAS TO FIND EMPLOYMENT.
HOW DO MORE TIME I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THE DIRE NEED
TO SUPPORT SUMMER CAL GRANT?
WITH THE COMBINED COST OF
UNIVERSITY TUITION TEXTBOOKS
RENT A MEAL PLAN TRANSPORTATION
AND BASIC LIVING EXPENSES.
WE NEED TO ASK OURSELVES
QUESTION SHOULD STUDENTS OF
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES HAVE AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
TOWARDS HIGHER EDUCATION.
BECAUSE AS OF NOW FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS --
BLACK IMPELLED AND BROWN PELL
GRANT RECIPIENTS AND ROLLED IN
THE UC.
GRADUATE ON TIME -- NO SUMMER
CAL GRANT IS WOULD BE YOU KNOW
SOME CALDERON WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE COURSE OF ACTION YOU
ARE LEGISLATORS CAN TAKE TO
ENSURE THAT LOW INCOME STUDENTS
CAN GRADUATE ON TIME AND IN FOUR
YEARS WITH LESS STUDENT DEBT.
OPERATIVE OPPORTUNITY GET SEASON
IMPACTED CLASSES AND LEAVE
SCHOOL EXCITED ABOUT THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
I'M.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF SEEN
THE GIANT HOT AIR BALLOON ON THE
FRONT LAWN BY TEN STREET.
BUT AS THE CHEN AYE MASTER YODA
HAD SAID.
MANY OF THE TRUTHS WE CLING TO
DEPEND ON OUR POINT OF VIEW.
SO WE CAN'T.
SO WE CAME HERE TODAY TO SHARE
OUR TRUTHS AND WE'RE READY TO
HELP YOU HELP US BY CHANCE.
CAMPAIGNING OUR CAUSE.
AND MAY THE FORCE BE WITH IF.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
DR YES MA'AM YEAH I GUESS SO
FOLLOW THAT UP HI MY NAME IS
GALINA WHITE IAM A FOURTH YEAR
STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA.
AND I'M ALSO HERE TO SAVE MYSELF
FOR THE SUMMER CAL GRANT OF FOR
A MULTITUDE OF REASONS ONE OF
WHICH IS.
PERCENT OF CSU STUDENTS AT THIS
TIME DO NOT GRADUATE ON TIME.
AND SUMMER PROGRAM WOULD
SERIOUSLY HELP WITH THAT I
BELIEVE IT'S CRUCIAL TO ENSURING
MORE EQUITY IN ACCESSIBILITY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION -- AND AS A
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENT MYSELF I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I WOULD HAVE SERIOUSLY
BENEFITED FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
THE SUMMER CAL GRANT.
DURING MY TIME AT UNIVERSITY SO
STATE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR JOINING
US -- OKAY SIR HELLO EVERYONE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
BE -- AND I'D LIKE TO VOTE ALSO
WITH MY SUPPORT FOR SUMMER CAL
GRANT NOW ASK FOR A STATE
FUNDING TO BE ALLOCATED TOWARDS
IS VERY IMPORTANT CAMPAIGN --
HUGE THANK YOU TO US IN A
RICHARD ROTH FOR HELPING
COALITION FOR A BETTER YOU SEE.
HOW TO MAKE THIS A REALLY BIG
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE A BIG DEAL SO A
LOT OF US -- STATE CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY PAYS ARE CURRENTLY
FINDS FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS PER STUDENT THEY DID FORTY
YEARS AGO -- WHICH ALL THESE
OTHER FOR INSTANCE ARE ABLE TO
GRADUATE ON TIME AT SUMMER CAL
GRANT REALLY HELP THE STUDENTS --
BE ABLE TO GRADUATE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY WHILE ALSO OFFERING OF
SPACE FOR THE FUTURE GENERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU YES MA'AM MY NAME'S
BARBARA SOLVED -- I HAD.
WANT TO SHARE MY ONE OF MY
FRIENDS PERSONAL STORY SHE CAME
FROM A VERY ABUSIVE FAMILY AND
JUST TO KEEP IT SHORT LIKE THE
WAY SHE WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY WAS
GOING TO COLLEGE AND STAYING IN
SUMMER SCHOOL. TO LIKE HAVING
CAL GRANTS AND FINANCIALLY
DURING THE SUMMER WOULD HELP
KEEP AWAY FROM AN ABUSIVE FAMILY.
YEAH.
SURE YES SIR HI MY NAME IS DOING
CC I'M A THIRD YEAR STUDENT.
CALIFORNIA AND I'D LIKE TO THANK --
CHAIRMAN ROTH IN THE OTHERS THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT OF
EXTENDING CAL GRANTS TO SUMMER --
I KNOW THAT AS A STUDENT WHO HAS
A TWENTY PLUS OUR AUTOMATIC
COMMITMENT ON TOP OF TWENTY PLUS
HOURS WORKING AND AN ACADEMIC
SCHEDULE -- A LOT OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE JUST LIKE ME ARE ONE
HEALTH CRISIS AWAY FROM DROPPING
OUT OF COLLEGE OR HAVING TO
SUSPEND THEIR EDUCATION -- WHICH
IS ALMOST SOMETHING I HAD TO DO
IN THE FALL.
PARTICULARLY SERIOUS CASE OF
PNEUMONIA -- AND STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL MEANS
OR THE ABILITY.
TO POSTPONED THAT EDUCATION
UNTIL THE SUMMER AND TAKE SUMMER
COURSES IN ORDER TO MAKE UP FOR
THIS.
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
HAVING TO PAY THOUSANDS MORE.
EXTRA QUARTERS.
I'M SO I JUST LIKE THANK YOU FOR
ADVOCATING FOR THIS ISSUE.
COMING YES MA'AM I RUN MY NAME
IS CONVERSION CHANT AND I'M A
FIRST YEAR STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO -- SO AS A FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOMESTUDENTS
MOVING AWAY COLLEGE FOR THE
FIRST TIME WAS A TRANSFORMATIVE
GETS.
SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WHEN I
FOUND OUT THE HEADS ZERO UNITS
ON THE FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL.
I WAS TERRIFIED -- I I WAS
THINKING ABOUT CALLING
APPEARANCE I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
TELL THEM I DON'T THINK I'M EVEN
A STUDENT NOW BECAUSE I'M NOT
ENROLLED IN ANY CLASSES AT ALL --
SO I WAS ON THE VERGE OF GETTING
MY FINANCIALLY TO VOTE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF I WAS GOING TO
MAKE IT TO COLLEGE I YOU KNOW IT.
COULD IT COULD ATTEND ANYMORE --
IT WAS FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THIS
IS DUE TO OVER ENROLLMENT IN
EXTREME WAIT LISTS -- STUFF I
HAD NO CONTROL OVER -- SO MY
GRADUATION DATE NOW COULD
POSSIBLY BE PUSHED BACK BECAUSE
OF CIRCUMSTANCES THAT.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONTROL -- SO
THIS IS WHY I THINK THE SUMMER
CAL GRANT FINANCIAL IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR ME IN OTHER
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN MY POSITION --
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
CAL GRANT -- ENCOURAGE YOU ALL
TO CONTINUE INVESTING IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORTING HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENT THANKS
FOR COMING.
YES.
HI MY NAME IS ANITA I'M A FOURTH
YEAR STUDENT FROM UCSD -- I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE UC
SYSTEM AND PARTICULAR THIS
SUMMER CAL GRANT BILL -- I
CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE IMPACT OF
STATE SUPPORT OF THE UC SYSTEM
BUT I HOPE SOME OF THE STORIES
HAVE.
HELPED PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE THE
EFFECT THAT FUNDING IS HAD ON
OUR EDUCATION AND THE OVERALL
STUDENT -- ONE THING THAT I
WANTED TO TOUCH UPON IS THE
AFTERMATH OF OVER ENROLLMENT
THEM I FOUND.
A FELLOW STUDENT HAD JUST
MENTIONED.
IN A SOCIETY THAT INCREASINGLY
EMPHASIZE EDUCATION ISN'T AND
IT'S INEVITABLE THAT STUDENT
ENROLLMENT CONTINUES TO GROW
EXPONENTIALLY.
WHAT IS NOT INEVITABLE IS THE
LACK OF HOUSINGTHE STUDENTS ARE
OFFERED -- I WAS IN ARE A LAST
YEAR AND MANY STUDENTS WERE
OFFERED A COUPLE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO MOVE OFF CAMPUS MADE
YEAR.
ON BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION HAD
DISPLACED MAY TRANSFER STUDENTS
WHO NOW DO NOT HAVE A PLACE TO
LIVE -- THOSE IN A COMPROMISE
FINANCIAL POSITION MAY HAVE FELT
COMPELLED TO TAKE THIS OFFER AND
WOULD HAVE BEEN LEFT SCRAMBLING
FOR HOUSING WHILE TRYING TO EARN
A DEGREE.
AND ARE THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
BE -- SO YOUR SUPPORT OF THE UC
BUDGET WOULD HELP PREVENT THE
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS HAVE ONE LESS THING TO
WORRY ABOUT WHAT PURSUING THEIR
DEGREE.
SO -- I WANT TO STATE MY STATE
MY SUPPORT -- FOR STATE MY
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE UC SYSTEM AND THANK YOU
AGAIN -- FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
HEAR US YOU SEE STUDENTS OUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY CHANGING OF THE GUARD.
HELLO MY NAME'S THE VETS I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THAT YOU SEE
ADVOCACY NETWORK ALSO KNOWN AS
YOU CAN -- I AM A FIRST YEAR
TRANSFER -- AT UCLA FROM FALSELY
COLLEGE -- AND I AM STUDYING
CHICANO CHICANA STUDIES AND
EARLIER SOMEONE MENTIONED HOW --
IT BEING AT THESE INSTITUTIONS
THAT WERE YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY
NOT MADE FOR US -- SPECIALLY FOR
MARCH STUDENTS OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES -- BEING THERE AND
ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL AID
THAT WE RECEIVE -- AND THEN
HAVING TO WORK -- ASIDE FROM
THAT AND NOT BEING ABLE TO GO
FULL COURSE SOMETIMES. FOR MOUNT
OR EXTRA CLASSES TO GRADUATE ON
TIME -- IT'S VERY HARD AND
DEFINITELY ADDS TO YOUR STRESS
LEVEL IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
BASICALLY EVERYTHING ELSE THEY
HAVE GOING ON IN LIFE -- SO I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SUMMER
CAL GRANT AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT THAT I MEAN SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OF MANY OTHER FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS ARE HERE --
THAT WOULD REALLY HELP US MOVE
ALONG AND YOU KNOW MAKE OUR
PROFESSIONAL -- GOALS.
ALL RIGHT TENER PROFESSIONAL
GOES MUCH FASTER AND MAKE OUR
CAREER OUR TIME AT A PLACE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION MUCH EASIER.
THANKS FOR JOINING YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WOULD LIKE TO
TING THANKS TO ROTH AND OTHERS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
ONE CALTRAIN EXPANSION I'M DOORS
A SOUND OF OFFERS YOUR
UNDERGRADUATE I UC SANTA CRUZ.
OTHER FIRST GENERATION NOTHING A
STUDENT GOING AWAY FOR COLLEGE
IS NOT EASY I'VE DEFINITELY HAD
MANY DOUBTS WITHIN MY FIRST YEAR.
THINKING I SHOULD HAVE GONE TO
COLLEGE BECAUSE IT'S SO
EXPENSIVE.
I KNOW SCHOOLS WHAT I WANT BUT
IS ROUGHLY ABOUT HOW TO COME UP
WITH MONEY LOANS THE GOVERNMENT
TUITION.
I DECIDED TO ATTEND THE FIRST
YEAR CADEMY DURING THE SUMMER
AT UCSC. FOR FALL QUARTER I
CAN'T HELP BUT FEEL LIKE A
BURDEN ON MY PARENTS.
THE ADDITIONAL COST OF ATTENDING
SCHOOL IN THE SUMMER I DO NOT
FEEL GUILTY PERSON HIRED.
I HOPE TO GRADUATE SOONER AND
SAVE SOME MONEY DURING THE
REGULAR SCHOOL YEAR IF QATAR
WERE TO BE EXPANDED TO SUMMER
SCHOOL TERMS.
PERHAPS MORE SO LIKE ME WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
AHEAD OF COURSE ISN'T SQUARELY
IN ORDER TO DO SOME MONEY.
YOU COME IN.
HI I AM IN THE FROM A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I SEE THAT OUR
STUDENTS STRUGGLING AT UC
BERKELEY SPECIFICALLY IS HAVING
STUDENT HOUSING.
SO -- ON TOP OF OUR NOT BEING
ABLE TO ENROLL IN CLASSES LIKE
ONE OF MY FELLOW YOU SEE AT
SINCE MENTIONED -- THAT WE ALSO
HAVE.
TO FIGHT FOR HOUSING AND WE ARE
FORCED TO LIVE OFF CAMPUS WHICH
IS HARDER BECAUSE NOW STUDENTS
ARE DOING DOUBLE JOBS JUST TO
PAY FOR TUITION AND HOUSING.
AND THIS IS A GREAT PART THIS IS
A LARGE PART IN ON THE STUDENTS
IN GENERAL BECAUSE OF THE
RIGOROUS OF ****.
AT BERKELEY AND ANY UC
INSTITUTION IN GENERAL SO -- WE
WOULD LOVE EXCERPTED PORT AND
WE'VE I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
GUYS AND THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO HONOR AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE WOULD OUR BEER WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION IN PERMANENT ONGOING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
TO HAVE.
MORE RESOURCES THE STUDENTS
WOULDN'T BE DOING DOUBLE JOBS --
SO THEY CAN.
FOCUS MORE ON EDUCATION WHAT
THEY'RE HERE FOR THEIR DEGREE
AND THEN GAIN THE SKILLS THAT
THEY REALLY NEED TO GO AND THE
WORK.
YES MA'AM HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA A STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY SO GOING OFF FROM WHAT
SHE SAID ABOUT -- HOW YOU SEE
NEEDS MORE BUDGET -- SO I AM
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN ONE OF THE
CLASSES WHICH HAS LIKE ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
BUT ONE OF THE CLASSROOM IS.
THE CITY IS ONLY ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED SO THE OTHER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO TO
ANOTHER CLASSROOM.
WHICH WILL BE WEBCAST SAID OR
LIKE WHAT VIRTUAL CAST THAT.
AND THAT END UP.
NOT HAPPENING AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO COME BACK TO THE ORGINAL
CLASSROOM WOULD FIVE HUNDRED TO
THAT ALREADY BEING IN THERE AND
THEY ARE TO HAVE TO SIT ON THE
STAIRS AND EVERYTHING.
MORE OVER LIKE WORK IF THE IN
ROMAN SEASON RIGHT NOW AND I'M
CURRENTLY WAIT LISTED ON THE ONE
OF THE SUBJECT.
WAIT LISTED ON THE NINETY FIRST
AND I'VE SEEN PEOPLE -- PLACE ON
THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ON THE
WAIT LIST AND EVEN THE WAIT LIST.
IS CLOSE RIGHT NOW SO THE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO EAT --
EITHER GRADUATE EARLY OR
GRADUATE ON TIME.
OR GETTING.
THE SUBJECT SON TO DECLARE THEIR
MAJOR IS THROUGH THE SUMMER
PROGRAMS.
AND ARE YOU WANT TO REALLY THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE A FOR THE YOU
HAVE TO PUT IN FOR THE SUMMER.
AND IT'S REALLY HELPFUL AND NEED
AT HI MY NAME.
HI MY NAME'S JOHN THEM WITH THE
YEAH YOU STILL WAY -- LIKE MANY
OTHERS I LIKE TO THANK WHICH
WITH THE CONSTANT LEADERSHIP ON
THE SOMEONE CAL GRANT --
SUPPORTING STUDENT GRADUATED
EARLY -- OR EVEN ON TIME IS
SOMETHING THAT IS CRITICAL IN
PROTECTING THE THE WELL KNOWN
AND RENOWNED ABILITY TO THE UC
SYSTEM.
ALLOWS ONE JUST REMINDS
COMMITTEE OF US BEFORE HE WAS
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND.
THERE'S A LOT OF THE FOR MATH
AND INTO THE SEA LEVEL AND WE
REALLY WANT TO FIX THIS.
FIX THESE LABS IN THE WE SHOULD
RESEARCH THE LECTURE HALLS BUT
WE HAVE MORE SENSIBILITIES FOR
STUDENTS.
SO YOU THANK YOU VOTE ON THE
WHOLE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING.
THANKS YOUR COMMENTS.
LEGISLATOR MY NAME IS GIOVANNI
TOLENTINO I'M A FIRST YEAR
STUDENT AT UCLA STUDY POLITICAL
SCIENCE -- AND LIKE MANY OF MY
PEERS I'D LIKE TO THINK OF THE
CHAIR FOR ITS CONTINUED SUPPORT
OF THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM PROGRAM --
HIS IN OTHER LEGISLATORS BACKING
IS -- CRITICAL TO THE CAUSE OF
MANY YOU SEE STUDENTS AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT FUTURE YOU SEE BUDGET
PRIORITIES.
I'M FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO ARE
TRYING TO GRADUATE EARLY ON I
FEEL LIKE A ROBUST FINANCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IS YOU KNOW
VERY CRITICAL BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES EASIER AND FASTER
ACCESS TO COURSES.
AND THIS GIVES US AN ADVANTAGE
IN PURSUING OUR CAREERS.
THANK YOU.
OF A CERTAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME'S
MICHAEL.
MICHAEL SESSION I ALSO TEN USE
YELLING INTO A YOU CAN
AMBASSADORS WELL ONE THE FIRST
AND FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
I'M FOR THE SUMMER CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND WANTED TO ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDE.
OUT FINANCIAL AID AND STUDENT
EXPERIENCE ON OUR CAMPUS AT UCLA --
WHAT MANY STUDENTS BEHIND ONCE
THEY?
BEGIN ATTENDING UCLA ESPECIALLY
DEALING WITH FINANCIAL AID AND
ESPECIALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES -- AS ONE OF THE
SISTERS FROM SANTA BARBARA
POINTED OUT.
AND WHAT I LEARNED FROM.
COURSE WITH DOCTOR TYRONE POWER.
ON OUR CAMPUS WAS THAT FOR MOST
OF THE BLACK POPULATION ON OUR
CAMPUS WHICH IS OUR READY ONLY A
4%.
AND HAS THE LOWEST RETENTION
RATE OF ANY STUDENT GROUPS.
ON CAMPUS.
THEIR NUMBER ONE REASON FOR
HAVING THAT RETENTION NUMBER IS
ABOUT FINANCIAL.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT.
COME UP REGARDING FINANCIALLY.
PRIMARILY TAKE PLACE AGAIN
WITHOUT WITH THE LACK OF SUMMER
AID BUT ALSO.
WITH.
PETITIONS -- AND AND BROKE RAMPS
THAT.
ARE [inaudible]
NOT.
SUITED TO STUDENTS ACTUAL --
LIFESTYLE SO.
IN MY EXPERIENCE.
WHEN I TRANSFERRED TO UCLA?
I HAD PREVIOUSLY.
LIVE WITH MY FATHER MY SOLE
SURVIVING.
AND BUT HAD SINCE THEN.
BOB.
NO LONGER LIVE WITH HIM WAS
PAYING MY OWN BILLS PAYING MY
WAY THROUGH COLLEGE WORKING
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TO SIXTY
pTO SCHOOL.
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD NOT ALLOW
ME TO CHANGE MY STATUS TO
INDEPENDENT.
AND WHAT I WAS TOLD UPON.
PROVIDING INFORMATION THAT.
WE HAD FILED TAXES SEPARATELY
THAT I'D SHOWN MY TAXES THAT I'D
HANG ON MY OWN BILLS.
WAS THAT BECAUSE I SIMPLY HAD
CONTACT WITH MY FATHER -- THIS
WAS A PHONE CALL.
OR WHAT HAVE YOU DEBT I COULD
NOT CHANGE MY STATUS TO
INDEPENDENT SO THEN THE SCHOOL
STILL LOOKED AT ME TOO HEY.
THE APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS OUT OF POCKET.
FROM WORKING FULL TIME -- WHILE
TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL WHICH
PREVENTING ME FROM BEING ABLE TO
HAVE HOUSING.
WHICH IS ANOTHER COMMON ISSUE ON
OUR CAMPUS.
A LOT OF STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS
AND FOR MYSELF I SPENT
APPROXIMATELY THREE QUARTERS.
SLEEPING IN MY CAR AND SLEEPING
IN MY GIRLFRIEND'S DORM ROOM ARE
TRYING TO PAY OUT OF POCKET.
TUITION ACTION AT BAY.
FOR SO I AM HERE TODAY JUST
BRING THOSE ISSUES TO LIGHT THAT --
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE.
ATTENTION TO DETAIL REGARDING --
THE ABILITY OF JUDGE
TRANSFERRING -- IN ITS STATUS
BUT ALSO [inaudible]
OF THE EFFECTS OF NOT HAVING.
TO HOUSE IN PURSUIT.
HELLO MY NAME IS VANESSA I AM A
JUNIOR TRANSFER STUDENT -- UC
IRVINE I AM A CRIMINOLOGY LONG
PLAY A MAJOR -- I AND IN SUPPORT
OF THE CALLED OUT FOR THE SUMMER
I THINK THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL AN
INSTRUMENTAL IN.
HELPING TO ACTIVATE GRADUATION
PROFIS -- IN ADDITION TO THAT I
ALSO DO THINK ABOUT -- OR OTHER
INTERNS ARE MAYBE NOT AS VOCAL
WITH FOR EXAMPLE -- SOMETIMES
LIKE MENTAL.
SORT OF SOME.
I AM VERY HAPPY THERE'S
SOMETHING AND YOU MUST COSTS AND
THEN YOU HAVE.
TO YOU THE FINAL.
WHY NOT AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
WHICH ALL?
RIGHT IMPACT.
A NEW DRESS.
SOMETHING LIKE.
BECAUSE THE SOFTWARE THAT OUT OF
OUR CONTROL YOU KNOW.
MIA AND WHY NOT [inaudible]
AND SO.
RECEIVE -- US CATHOLIC -- HELLO
THIS IS SOMETHING LIKE. TO HELP
STUDENTS THE POINTERS.
AND NOT JUST PHYSICAL.
AND NOT USE YOUR ACTUALLY
HELPING [inaudible]
TWENTY I'VE ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ENOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR COMING OUT FOR
YOUR COMMENTS [inaudible]
YEAH.
HELLO MY NAME IS A MEAN ALMOST
NOON AND I'M A STUDENT CENTER AT
THE ENDS AND I ALSO SERVE ON THE
STUDENT CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I'D FIRST
LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN
STUDENTS ALL OVER THE STATE.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE YOU AWARE
OF A CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
OVER AT THE AS A JUST YESTERDAY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR OWN STUDENTS SENATE
UNFORTUNATELY OPPORTUNITIES TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY AND MAKE
THEIR COMMUNITY MORE ACTUAL
PLACE.
ARE OFTEN FROZEN OFFER MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE HAVING TO
TAKE TEN TO TWENTY HOURS OFF A
WEEK TO GO AND SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES IS SIMPLY UNFEASIBLE
FOR MANY OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND MORE BROADLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT HOW FINANCIAL IT IS CONSIDER
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CALLED
STUDENTS.
THINGS LIKE COST OF LIVING AND
STUFF LIKE THAT JUST SIMPLY
AREN'T CONSIDERED WHEREAS FOR
THE UC AND CSU SYSTEM THEY MIGHT
BE.
SO I LIKE TO REITERATE THE
SUPPORT NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA ME
COST OUR STUDENTS SO THAT THE
POSITIVE EXTERNALITIES WILL
BLEED OUT AND THEN MAKE THEM
MORE VIBRANT PLACE FOR ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO REITERATE THE FACT
THAT THE COMMITTEE CALLED SYSTEM
DOES SERVE MANY OF OUR MOST
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES
WHETHER THAT BE THE VETERAN OR
THE HOMELESS POPULATIONS.
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
MINORITY GROUPS AS WELL AND I'D
LIKE -- TO CONTINUOUSLY ASK YOU
GUYS. FOR INCREASING OPTIONS FOR
COMEY COSTUMES AS WELL STUDENTS
ACROSS ALL THREE BRANCHES OF OUR
SYSTEM.
OF BECAUSE I DO WE BELIEVE THAT
IT IS THE LIFE FORCE OF THE
STATE AND WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE STATE A WONDERFUL PLACE FOR
ALL OF US -- THANK YOU.
YOU FOR JOINING US AND THANKS
FOR YOUR COMMENTS [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME'S
MICHELLE HOW ARE AND I AM THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF SYSTEM AFFAIRS
FOR THE STUDENTS AND OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
I AM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
AT DE ANZA COLLEGE.
AND WHAT AND MY FRIEND AMY WAS
TALKING ABOUT IS THAT THERE IS.
HI LEAH AND AN EQUITABLE KIND OF
FIND FINANCIAL AID FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WE GET SENSE TO WHAT.
DOLLARS THE UC STUDENTS GET.
AND PEOPLE THINK THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS THE CHEAPER OPTION
BUT THAT JUST ISN'T IT -- WE DO.
NOT.
NORMALLY STUDENTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS DON'T REALLY
GET AID I JUST RECENTLY A GUY.
GOT ACCEPTED INTO UC DAVIS AND
THE FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE THEY
GAVE ME COVERED ALL OF MY
TUITION.
BUT WHILE I WAS THE AND I WASN'T
ABLE TO GET ANY FINANCIAL AID --
AND THAT WAS JUST REALLY WEIRD
TO ME THAT WAS VERY ALARMING --
BECAUSE WHAT MOST PEOPLE ASSUME
IS THAT STUDENTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LIVE AT HOME
WITH THEIR PARENTS JUST LIKE
THEY DID IN HIGH SCHOOL THEY
DON'T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT THINGS
LIKE HOUSING AND EVERYTHING.
BUT THE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS THAT ARE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE VERY
DIVERSE THEY'RE THE MOST
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITY HERE.
AND I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
SUPPORT THEM THAT'S WHY AND THE
STUDENTS AND OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUPPORTS SB
TWO NINETY ONE WRITTEN BY --
SENATOR LEYVA AND WE JUST WANT
TO AGAIN THANK YOU. FOR
EVERYTHING THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR RAWSON.
MY NAME'S SURGERY SO I REPRESENT
THE KELSEY SINICIZATION WE'RE
REPRESENTS HALF MILLION CSU
STUDENTS ON STATEWIDE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THE SUMMER CAL GRANT BILL AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATURE FOR
FOCUSING ON FINANCIAL AID REFORM
INVESTMENT THIS YEAR -- IN
INCLUDING SUMMER CAL GRANT
INCLUDING -- INCREASE
COMPETITIVE AWARDS FOR FOR
STUDENTS AND REMOVING
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED THEM AND YOU
WANT TO KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE FOR CSU
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR AND NOT A
COUPLE OF US IT TO STICK.
THE CSU ONLY 22% OF THE TOTAL
COST IS TUITION 60% OF OUR
STUDENTS DON'T PAY ANY TUITION
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF CAL
GRANT PAL AND SUB.
I'M AND 80% OF OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVE SOME FORM OF FINANCIAL.
AND THEY'RE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES ARE NOT MATT SO
HAVING A FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
THAT DOES COVER THAT FULL COST
OF ATTENDANCE OR HELP COVER MORE
OF THAT FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
IS A HUGE PRIORITY FOR US IN OUR
STUDENTSAND WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THIS COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO FOCUS.
WELL AS FINANCIALLY.
FOR FINANCIAL AID REFORM IN
GENERAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM YOU MAY BE IT.
WHEN I LEFT AFTERNOON MY MY
VALLEY CAN KATE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE AND I ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE?
USER THAT JUST SPOKE BUT WE ALSO
ECHO SOME OF THE SENTIMENTS THAT
WE'RE SHARE TODAY FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE DAVID O'BRIEN AND SEES
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU DIDN'T OF
PARENTS AND THE HOW GRANT BEFORE
THAT.
THE STREAMLINING OF C. SAP.
HOW FRANCE AS THE CIVIC WE WE
THINK THAT THE?
US IS READY NOW -- AND THAT THE
NEED FIRST.
WITH STUDENTS IS SO GREAT THAT
WE NEED TO MOVE.
ON WITH SOME URGENCY AND REALLY
PRIORITIZE THE HIGHEST NEED
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- POSSIBLY
THROUGH A FORMULA THAT CONSIDERS
SOME OF THE OF FACTORS SUCH AS
STUDENT PARENTS.
AND AMONG A VARIETY OF OTHER
FACTORS THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION TODAY ON THE REFORM
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE GOVERNOR
ON THE STATE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE COMPLETED
BUSINESS AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE SO THIS SUB COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED